e
a
train I think he's off of bit but he's
good morning everybody and happy
Monday I hope you all had a nice restful
week last week I did that's good cuz we
got I know you
so we're going to open the hearing on HB
748 establishing a local education
Freedom account program and I welcome
verville welcome to education
policy thank you madam chair um good
morning U Madam chair honorable
colleagues um I'm going to present uh
House Bill 748 for you for the record
I'm Kevin verville I presentent
Rockingham second district serving the
towns of Auburn Candia and and
Deerfield I'd like to give you a little
background um about me in case you're
not aware so um I'm a New Hampshire
native I was raised in pmri I attended
the pem public school system through
grade8 um my parents in their Infinite
Wisdom chose to send me to Bishop Brady
High School uh here in conquer for for
high school I attended uh Plum State
College it's plum State University now
was lowly College when I attended there
and I got a degree in physical science
secondary Ed with a chemistry
option um I I worked both as a as a
chemist and an educator I held an
experienced educator certificate from uh
the New Hampshire Department of
Education taught for several years um I
also attended uh graduate school at tane
University in New Orleans so I am a
public I am a product of the public
school system as well as the private
school system uh both religious and
non-religious private schools and I've
taught in the public school systems uh
in both uh Massachusetts and New
Hampshire I did a long-term sub
assignment um in North Andover
Massachusetts and I was a science
teacher at Hollis Brook line high school
for for several years I'm currently the
technical director for a company called
Summit packaging system with
headquarters in in Manchester New
Hampshire so House Bill 748 is relative
to public
education and we should really we should
really understand what the what my
perspective what my view of of the
definition of public
education public education in New
Hampshire means that each local
community has an obligation to educate
the children in their Community inherent
in this responsibility is the Public
Funding for the education of all
children
so so we we speak of public education
really what we're talking about is we're
talking about the the financing the the
funding public education does not
necessarily have to take place in a
public school right public education can
can take place in in a lot of different
locations and so that's what this bill
is is based on Modern thinking on
education is to provide that which is in
the the best interest of the student and
it's hard to imagine that requiring
attendance to a particular School based
on a student's home address will provide
students with the education that is in
interest if we consider special
education children a special education
system each receive an IEP an individual
education plan to ensure that the child
receives an individualized education
that is in the best interest of the
student further those requiring the most
specialized individual education plan
are often sent to or tuition into
private schools most of which are out of
District that are capable of providing
for the needs that are in the child's
best interest so the concept and
practice of using local taxpayer
education Monies to send students to
private institutions for public
education is already in common practice
in fact my hometown of of Deerfield we
we we only have a prek through eight
school we have no high school so we we
have no other option but to tuition our
students to other schools uh currently
we uh have the option of conquered High
School not in not in our SAU we're
deerfields SAU 53 coob Brown Northwood
Academy not in our not in our SA or
pemrick Academy which is in RS um
currently we have about a third of our
students attending Co Brown about 2third
attending conquer and only only a couple
of kids that that choose pem
Academy two years ago it was virtually
100% conquered high school because we
had an exclusive contract right it's
only in the last two years that
Deerfield um moved away from a one
school high school option to a multiple
High School option it is expected that
in the next school year I'm sorry the
school year after the next school year
it'll be an even split between Co Brown
and conquered high school and the year
after that we expect two-thirds of the
students to be going to to coob Brown
Brown this bill is enabling
legislation so nobody is forced to do
anything the bill has very low ballot
access very low threshold for ballot
access so it only takes a a small number
of petitioners to place the question
onto the onto the onto the local
ballot that's good because it's ease of
access the threshold to enable a local
education Freedom account is relatively
high it's 60% right so it's a super
majority at The Ballot Box so it's easy
to ask the question it's not so easy to
pass the question
if a district chooses to enable local
efas and after a year two years 5 years
10 years whatever whatever period of
time if the district no longer believes
that that program is in the best
interest of their community of their
students then the program can be
repealed the ballot access for the
repeal question is the same loow
threshold as the uh threshold to put it
on the ballot to to initiate the
program and the threshold to repeal is
the same as the threshold to enable so
it requires a 60% vote to disable the
disable the program
okay it allows the voters it allows the
voters of the the citizens of the
community to decide whether or not they
want to make this program available to
their
students the local
EFA
Bill
counts EFA students so if you enable the
program and a student avails themsel of
a local EFA because they don't have
to then they are counted in the district
for the average daily
membership that's important because
they're count as part of the average
daily membership the state adequacy
funds as well as other funds special ed
monies
Etc continue to flow from the state into
the
district the EFA amount is twice state
adequacy so that is to say the state
adequacy Grant would basically be a pass
through from the state to the district
to the
EFA and the Local District would match
those
funds so currently uh state adequacy
grants are a little less than
$5,000 and so if a community chose to
enable this then that five that little
less than 5,000 from the state would
flow into the EA and then the district
would match that amount into the
EFA
okay there's certain Financial safety
nets for for everybody involved so for
first of all the firste
grant sets a minimum
threshold so if I if I take an EFA this
year my grant is
X subsequent years going forward for
that child for that student the grant
would never be less than that so that
way the family knows what their what
their minimum threshold funding is going
to
be the grant is recalculated
annually so if the adequacy the state
adequacy number moves then the local
number would move up or
down but if it moves down it never goes
below the first year funding for that
student that's a family safety
net if a child takes an EFA and they get
to 20 they graduate high school
whichever comes first if there's money
left over in the EFA account that money
reverts back to the local school
district so any unspent monies goes back
uh to the general fund of the of the
district special education in the bill
is specifically called
out to be at the discretion of the local
school
district so special education does not
change for the district or for the
student special ed
location of services from an IEP are at
the discretion of the school
district so let's say we have a student
that needs speech therapy or help in
math or you know whatever the case may
be if the school district says look we
provide that service inhouse in this
school and and this is where the service
is available then then somebody taking a
local EFA they have to agree to that
they have to agree that the local
district has a discretion of where the
special ed takes
place so that's important because what
it does is it prevents um somebody from
from getting uh tuition into a school
that doesn't offer the surface right and
then mandating that either that school
offer it or that the the the sending
District The Local District would have
to pay for it there right because that
that creates a a very high financial
burden on local school districts already
financially um struggling for for
various reasons so the special ed stays
in place at the discretion of the The
Local District uh District the the IEP
process doesn't change right so the the
the development of an IEP is is is in
partnership with a local school district
uh the family and the student right so
that that process Remains the Same and
intact you just you simply can't take a
local EFA and then demand special ed
services wherever uh wherever you you
want to go to go get
that uh so that that's an important
bill the the other thing that's
important is that we hear a lot of
complaints relative to the state EFA
program relative to accountability
right that that the the public school
system has a level of accountability
that that some would say does not exist
outside of the public school
system and so uh to reach to reach
across to try to bridge that Gap because
I I'm not convinced that that's true but
to bridge that Gap the this bill 748
requires that local EFA particip ANS
take the New Hampshire Statewide
assessment system
evaluations right assessments as
scheduled by the
state that's the same
accountability that we use for local
public schools right that's that's the
accountability method is the just it
used to be the the kneecap then it was
smarter balance for a few years now it's
New Hampshire SAS
right the reason I'm not convinced about
the accountability um
claim is when we look at when we look at
assessment results even though New
Hampshire is one of the best
academically best performing states in
the nation we still struggle to get
proficiency rates at at
50% and yet I don't hear anybody
clamoring to somehow remedy that right
that's a it's a local control
issue but that is the accountability
vehicle and so um that remain means to
be the accountability uh vehicle in this
in this bill I don't I don't want to
take I've already taken up 15 minutes of
your time I I don't want to take up any
more um I would certainly be willing to
answer any and all questions that uh
members may have thank you I have one
question the local match doesn't they
don't match differentiated Aid
correct yeah thank you for the question
so um when I was looking at the fiscal
note on this bill um I believe the
department of Education um got it
incorrect right in their calculation the
the the local EFA Grant is double State
adequacy
period but uh the the other potential uh
funding sources and and let me just get
to that that list so I don't misquote it
um free and reduced um meals special
education Aid English language earner um
none of that would be doubled that money
would still flow to the child but not at
Double the rate it's it's only the the
the other thing is that's important to
note is there's no double dipping right
so the New Hampshire um scholarship
which is by business tax donation uh you
can't take a local EFA and participate
in that and you cannot participate in a
local EFA and a state EFA because you
are counted as average daily membership
you you are technically a member of that
school district even though you're
you're you're going to get your
education somewhere else so you cannot
get a local EFA and a state EFA right so
it's it's one or the other if any thank
you thank you for the question any
questions representative
Woodcock thank you manam chair good
morning good morning uh just a couple if
I may um going back to the special
education funding uh qu professional
education if a youngster was taking the
local EFA then why would the local
school system still be required to pay
for the special education program and
provide it they sort of opted out of the
local system but now you're saying the
the local system has to still provide
the special education training for yeah
thank you for the question
representative it's it's always an
interesting um it's always an
interesting sort of debate as to how we
how we choose to handle special
education right so my interest my
motivation is to provide what is in the
best interest of the child the best
interest of the student right the best
interest of the student is to not offer
money to leave the district at the cost
of having special ed Stripped Away but I
also believe that it's an unreasonable
burden to say if you choose to go
elsewhere then the the the special ed
has to follow you right so because that
that becomes financially very burdensome
with transportation and other issues
interestingly locala you you lose the
the the transportation and so it's it's
to try to find um a happy medium a place
in the middle that works for everybody
so because the special ed is still in
the Local District at their discretion
there really should be no change to cost
to the district for that right because
it's the same services in the same place
that would otherwise be offered and it's
up to the the student or the student's
family to get them to and from that
location so to me um that seems like a a
happy medium to to best meet everybody's
needs I follow up thank you um a
different question but I want to go back
to the special ed piece again if if the
if the youngster is going to uh Play
Somewhere Else EFA and you're under your
program and they come back to the school
district I think did I hear you say
initially that the
additional revenue for free reduced
special dispensation uh ESL uh those
three or four different differentiated
increases in uh the money for would flow
through the student I think I heard you
say that that that's that's the way the
bills R okay so if they flow through
then the then the local community would
not be getting any of the special ed
funding to help support that youngster
um but you're they're coming back and
stff to take special in the in the
community you see what I mean oh I I I
fully connect the dots and and I'm not
I'm certainly not going to to disagree
with you um the the amount of money
that's flowing from the state is
relatively small right one of the
biggest challenges with special ed and
one of the reasons special ed is
swamping so many school districts local
budgets is because special ed really is
a federal mandate is and the state law
mirrors the federal requirements but
it's not really a state requirement it's
a federal requirement and unfortunately
the federal government refuses to fully
fund the special ed mandates that it
puts on States and local school
districts and so well I don't disagree
that you you could have you could have
that right the question is how many how
many special ed students will take a
local EFA but come back for special ed
you know that that's hard to predict um
I I would say that that we could come
back and and fix that in the future if
it became if it became an issue um I
don't I don't want to let the perfect
become the enemy of the good
respectfully thank you m CH sure
represent Murray thank you madam chair
thanks for taking my question if I'm
understanding you correctly with regard
to special ed Transportation you're
stating that it would be 100% the
parents fiscal responsibility to find a
vehicle a transportation modality to um
transport a child to a location of
they're
choosing yeah thank you for the question
so it's actually transportation is
actually you know universally the
responsibility of the the student or the
student's family right they are excuse
me they are counted as for uh average
daily membership so that the state funds
still flow into the district but just
like any child that that leaves a school
district thing the burden of
Transportation now is on that student or
that student's family so so if I choose
to let's say I chose to do what my
parents chose to do right and send my
kids to Bishop Brady High School and
then I'm on the hook for that for that
well it's a bad I'm sorry that's a bad
example because there's no legal
requirement to provide High School
transportation so let me back up a
little bit so let's say that um I chose
to be more proactive than my parents and
send my uh children to say St John's
here in conquer right which is uh
through grade 8 last I
knew if I make that choice then I have
to provide the transportation to and
from that school that becomes my that
becomes my
responsibility um if I may ask even
though the IEP May specifically
enumerate services that are included and
transportation is included in that so in
the plan for example how the child is
transported on and off the bus or
anything like that that might be
specified in the child's IEP how can
that how how can you be recognizing the
IEP and then in one in one instance and
then for transportation purposes related
to that not recogniz yeah I yeah I
better understand your question now I
apologize for not not seeing forward
enough so there's there's two different
worlds that we're talking about right
there is there is one where um little
Kevin needs uh needs help with
articulation
of the spoken word right and so that's a
service that I that I get my local
District
school but now I'm choosing a local EFA
so I'm not there anymore if I still want
to Avail myself of the articulation
assistance right then it's it's the
burden on me or my family to get me to
and from there once it is once
transportation is placed into an IEP
right so we can we can imagine um a
student that is in some certain
condition that requires special
Transportation then then it would be my
understanding that that that would that
would still flow as it does
today right because it's specified in
the IP so you can't you can't if it's in
the IEP you cannot say
no okay follow up sure don't be sorry
it's all fun so then if a service
provider for example comes into the
district uh initially or travels to a
school like often happens to provide
services for a child they're also then
coming to provide services and then may
leave at once they're done providing
services to a student or multiple
students throughout the day and head to
their next placement um to address other
students so how are you how are
you stating that those services or are
you're you're forgoing those with regard
to to local I'm having a hard time
understanding where those where that
wall ends sure I think I understand the
question so a local EFA is a choice it
is a choice it is a choice that a
student makes it is a choice that the
student's family makes right to
determine for themselves what is in the
best interest of the
child and so if if my special service is
speech
articulation and it is offered Tuesday
at 9:00 a.m. at the Deerfield community
school because that's where I live is in
Deerfield then if I want to continue to
Avail myself of that it is the burden on
me or my family to get me to that school
for 9:00 speech therapy that's
articulation that that's that's the
challenge right with with Choice it's
not it's not hey I get to take the money
and I get to have everything that I want
there's there's pluses and minuses
there's tradeoffs and and if you if you
can't make that
work right if you can't make that work
and you believe that that's critical to
the best interest of the child then you
have to make a different decision right
there's there's no it it all goes back
to there is no one size fits
all okay so I have twin
daughters one wants to go into Musical
theater the other I would qualify as an
academic right just a little
Brainiac conquered High School in crtc
has probably hands down the best theater
program in the state of New Hampshire
and at the time my children entered high
school that was our school of
record and she was excited she was over
the moon to be able to attend that
program right that's great
that's
awesome my other daughter looked at the
academic program at conquer high school
and with all due respect in in her
assessment and in our assessment we
found it to be uh lacking not not up to
what would be in the best interest of
our
child and for that reason we sent one of
our daughters to coob Brown Northwood
Academy before it was a choice for
Deerfield because we believe that was in
the best interest of the child
right so no we we had we had a boss to
conquer it so transportation's there
there's no transportation to to co Brown
you know we we made it work was it easy
no but it was a choice it was a choice
we made this this bill simply opens up
choices since I'm on the since I'm on
the
theme the current EFA
program allows enough money so that some
families where other options in the
Local District
school are Out Of Reach they it can it
can help them bridge that
Gap if you double that amount if you
double that amount you make other
opportunities fairly close to Universal
will everybody be able to afford
wherever they want to go no but this
amount of money would put a lot of
options into the reach of a lot of
families a lot of
students one of the things that that
people say is well you know if you have
this you're going to you're going to
decimate the local public school you're
going to decimate it I don't believe
that because the only way you decimate
it is if kids leave right if your local
public school is not attracting local
students right if if if people start
taking efas and going other places that
should tell your local school they are
not providing the goods and services
that their customers
want think about the vantages of a local
public school one is transportation is
guaranteed through grade eight although
not required After High School most
people want their children to be raised
in the local community they want them to
have a sense of place right that I grew
up here I grew up in Penbrook I am proud
I grew up in Penbrook most of us are
proud of where we grew up right oh I
grew up here great place loved it not
everybody most people most people want
that right most people want their their
kids to be raised with their friends and
neighbors kids that live in their
Community it's a short commute for the
for the most part local schools are are
the are the closest option right with
Transportation there's a lot of
advantages there a lot of advantages but
there is no one school that fits every
kid that fits every every opportunity
and all I'm trying to do is to find a
mechanism to allow communities to open
up uh opportunities to to
students representative Cornell thank
you mam chair thank you for taking my
question I couldn't see an income
eligibility on this cap for so I have a
question if if I make
$750,000 a year and I want to send my
child to St Paul's and they'll get um
the money from the local taxpayer the
property taxes but my neighbor makes
$65,000 a year their property taxes are
going to be paying to send my child to
St Paul's when I make
$750,000 a year can can I ask a personal
question yes what what community did you
raise your children in I I don't want to
answer pick pick one pick a pick a town
at random Manchester and when you when
you so you're making
$750,000 which is awesome good for you
I'm glad you're successful this is this
is an example this isn't me I I
understand so we're just in the
hypothetical all right and so when when
you brought your children to the
Manchester School District did they ask
you how much you earn to determine what
access to local public education you
would get for
free I don't that's not answering the
question public education is available
to everybody St Paul's is not available
to everybody okay thank you so so public
education is available to everybody we
do not means test public education in
New Hampshire right except for local
except for State efas hold on allow me
to to answer the question please we do
not means test public education in New
Hampshire in fact I would say it is
antithetical to the New Hampshire
tradition to means test for access to
public
education this is a local
EFA for me local public education is the
funding of a child's educ ation using
public monies it is not about the school
that the child attends or where they get
the education so if if so when I brought
my kids to the dfield community
school at young age they did that say Mr
Mrs verbel how much do you make oh you
make that much you can have English and
math for free if you want anything
beyond that you have to chip in we do
not means test public educ not answering
my question my question was I don't
think do you think it's fair that the
person making $65,000 a year and paying
property taxes is contributing to your
child to go to St Paul's when you make
$750,000 a year and that's a choice you
were talking about choices it's a choice
to go to St Paul's if you make that
choice you pay for it
correct thank you now allow me to answer
the question if if if I may you ask the
question allow me the the the
opportunity to answer it so the local
EFA is going to generate less than
$10,000 I have to admit I have not
pinged uh St Paul's School for what
their tuition rate is I'm going to
assume it's significantly higher than
that right and so you are still going to
pay because the local EFA is not going
to pay all of that tuition right it's
probably going to it's probably going to
help yes what about what about the
families that don't have
children is it fair for them to pay for
your child's education yes okay so so
then it's then it's fair for them to if
I may finish the answer back do we have
rules here with resp colloques yes we've
already had enough questions uh we're
not doing it back and forth It's not a
debate thank you m
chair
representative thank you uh in your
extended remarks you actually kind of
brushed uh past or began to delve into
the question that I was going to ask
earlier but I'm still going to ask it
but a little bit differently and that is
um I I I I see from the 40,000 F foot
level we've gone into quite a lot of
detail here from the 40,000 foot level
um there there seems to be an objection
to a program such as this one and and
efas in general um that is expressed and
has been expressed by candidates in the
last election at the very least that if
programs such as this one were to be
implemented that this would d destroy
the public schools um are you aware of
that argument and which it appears that
you are and what do you believes the
rational and realistic basis for
believing that providing an alternative
such as this one to parents who are
taxpayers in with in their districts to
make a choice such as this one um what
what's the rational and realistic fear a
basis for that fear do you believe thank
thank you for the question you agree
with that thank you for question
representative I I I appreciate it so so
certainly um one of the things that that
we constantly hear is that school choice
will destroy um local public education
in the state of New Hampshire or any
place that it's that it's
introduced I do not believe
that in
fact if if you do believe that right
then then the burden should be on you to
explain
why now I can I can
hypothesize a potential
scenario where perhaps that might
begin so you can
imagine that I live in a
district where my local public
school is
failing and let's define failing right
so since the since the the the means of
fig figuring out the accountability of a
school we're looking at proficiency
rates on the state
assessment and there are
districts that year after
year struggle to hit 25% of their
students
proficient it's tragic it's absolutely
tragic and and it's not about teaching
to the test right we're talking about
English language arts mathematics basic
science at at grade four through eight
and as junior in high school so we're
not we're not talking about doctoral
dissertations so imagine imagine we have
this this failing local public
school and all of a sudden the people
that live in that District have access
to enough money that allows them another
choice to a school that they believe
will provide a better educational
opportunity I can imagine a lot of
people wanting to Avail themselves of
that opportunity to get their children
out of that failing
school and I wouldn't blame them a
bit what I would
say is that none of this can shift
quickly fact of the matter is there's no
seats there's no available seats there
aren't enough open seats in private
schools and other settings in this new
in this state for a mass exitus out of
the public school
system now if we enable the
program and all the available seats what
few there are get
filled my gut tells me the market will
respond and that private schools will
try to increase their capacity to to to
do what's in their best interest as a
school and then as those seats become
available you can imagine more children
moving out of that District but we're
talking about processes that take uh
several
years and I would hope that the local
school district when they see this trend
retool what they're doing to reattach
their customers their local students to
school follow up and we're going to take
one more question after this followup is
is what you've just described not at the
very heart of competition as opposed to
Monopoly thank you for the question so
so that is one of the challenges with um
local public schools is they are a
monopoly right and the only way out of
the Monopoly is to have enough money
after you pay for the local school and
your local property tax to have enough
money left over for another opportunity
and and so yes it when we look at
schools that are failing year after year
after year less than 25% proficient
English language arts mathematics and
science I would agree that interjecting
some competition for those students
would be the way to entice those schools
to improve the product and services
they're offering their local customers
thank you one more question
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um this might be a little bit
clunky but on page six uh line 30 um
section 4 I think this is regarding the
superintendent of the Local District
notifying students of their
determination and eligibility
no later than July so I'm sorry so I'm
on page six the lines please four um
line 30
please it's uh sub paragraph 4 yes um
talking about eligibility determination
by July
14th um so my question to you would be
um a couple of things with regard to the
scholarship organization um being
responsible for the initial receipt of
funds correct you describ this as a pass
through from the scholarship
organization then to the state and then
local level correct so if the question
is the mechanism I'm not I'm not fully
to the question hold on one second no no
that but the initial question is is
what's what's the what's the flow of the
money right and so this that's not my
question just one second please okay so
you don't have a question I got continue
the question that I do have is in the
event that a student enrolls later um in
the year after July 14th how is
eligibility then determined is that a is
that something that um the district will
communicate with a scholarship
organization to determine if there are
funds available and then um in addition
to that how do you then notify folks
after the July 14th deadline because
oftentimes people move throughout the
year yeah that's an that's an excellent
question so first of all the the way the
money moves is the same as the state EFA
uh but instead of coming from um the the
State Treasury Department it comes from
the the local school district right and
the the timing of those payments uh is
set up to to go along with the timing of
um this there there is no um there's no
pration currently in this in this bill
so it is my understanding that basically
you would start at the beginning of the
year um if you um if you come out of it
early then uh the money would go back to
the to the Local
District thank you thank you
representative
verbil could you fill out a pink card
apologies thank
we're going to do a uh three minute time
limit well I said on five minutes and
what I have to say he took a lot of time
so yeah we always give preference to the
prime sponsor to legis but actually one
of the things that he pointed out was in
my um testimony and he had clarified
that so maybe I feel like what I have to
say it's going to be five minutes I'll
try to make it shorter so um Madame
chair and uh Vice chair and the members
of the education policy Administration
committee I would like to um introduce
myself my name is Patty long and I from
Peterboro and I'm a retired public
school teacher I'm also a parent of two
daughters who attended Catholic
school and I am a parent of a son who
went through the public
school I am here today in strong
opposition uh to HB 748 establishing a
local education Freedom account program
LFA we all know that New Hampshire
schools are primarily funded by our
property
taxpayers the proposed
legislation will be double the current
cost of the education Freedom account
now do I understand understand that
correctly I hope I do because it seems
like the numbers didn't add up but I'm
going to go on the expense for the
student toes an
$853 and
28 this is double the current cost of an
EFA so they said that they were going to
double according to the bill the way it
was presented everything was being d
doubled so I was understanding that if
you received reduced aid for Meal
special education and an English
language learner would receive a total
over
$119,000 which is actually income
taxfree to their family which would be
deposited into the class Wallet account
however the person that presented the
bill said that that was incorrect so
thankfully that is because otherwise if
you're a family of four it would have
cost 77,000
to educate those four children so I'm
going to go on to my next point in the
bill it propo the proposed legislation
Grant they want it to be administered by
the local school district and a
scholarship organization right now the
EFA funds are currently administered by
the children's scholarship fund this PL
this organization is located in New York
City and they presently receive
10% of the total value of every
EFA for the year 2024 the children's
scholarship organization received over
$1.8 million just to administer the fund
which was paid using New Hampshire tax
dollars these administrators of costs
include large salaries for one or more
administrators and these administrative
costs do not deliver direct academic
support and educational programs for our
students I want to talk to the bill
where it talks about that there
accessing the program there still would
be the ability to use um qualifying
expenditures lefas would be available to
families who wish to educate their
children outside of the state public
school system and would allow to buy
educational programs and services
presently the EFA funds are accessible
to parents with their class wallet
accounts which are used for private
school tuition private music lessons ski
lift tickets gymnastics classes
horseback riding ballet classes as well
as the purchase of non returnable items
such as school uniforms ski equipment
and even posos why would taxpayers agree
to having the children's scholarship
organization
oversee these unchecked expenditures
from their local school property tax
excuse me we we've hit the time limit
can you just make your last point I'm
going we all have my I hope you read so
I'm going to give my last point the
bottom line is this if this legislation
passes then someday Little Johnny being
a beneficiary of the local education
Freedom account expansion will no longer
be in public school while little Susie
who once sat beside him her education
funding is now worth half of what
Johnny's is is that what we taxpayers
and citizens really want for the future
of our children I hope during your
executive session I ask you to consider
the negative financial implications to
TA to the New Hampshire taxpayers and
more important importantly the adverse
education opportunities it will impose
on children in our Public Schools if
this legislation is to pass I thank you
very much for your time thank you any
questions representative McDonald thank
you madam chair and thank you Miss Lan
for being here and for your extensive
testimony just taking a look at this it
appears to be the list of vendors that
efas have been used for and it came
directly from the children's scholarship
fund website that is correct okay and
there's a number of highlights and notes
written in the margins particularly
every time that Amazon was used as a
vendor it's highlighted is there a
reason for that I believe it's the
second largest vendor on here if not the
first why every expense is highlighted
was there something to note from that
yes because there was actually spent
$1.4
million went through the children's
scholarship fund to purchase items that
fell in the category so I'm hoping that
the children's scholarship fund is
looking carefully at what is being
purchased because you really can buy
anything from Amazon I'm hoping it's
educational and if I may have a followup
Madam chair are you aware of the
scholarship fund using an application
called class wallet to verify these
purchases from Amazon in particular and
that that yes I'm very aware of it and
actually I've done extensive research on
the qualifying expenditures and I also
went to the New Hampshire Department of
Ed website to see if those expenditures
were on the list from the Department of
Ed and many of them didn't even appear
and that's why many of them are
highlighted all right thank you any
other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so much for allowing me to speak to
Wells we're going to do three minutes
thank you uh good morning U thank you
for allowing me to speak um my name is
Ted Wells and I'm uh again HB
428 um I'm against vouchers and local
school vouchers um I'm the product of K
through 12 public schools in New
Hampshire um I'm um a parent a taxpayer
and a public school teacher um I have a
unique perspective I taught private
school for 15 years in Massachusetts I
moved back home I'm now teaching public
school it's been eight years in the
Hopkin School District where I grew up
and went to school um why am I not at
school today our water M broke um
outside the Maple Street School um where
I teach sixth grade it's a 456 school um
got a text at 511
a.m. um was sleeping in the bottom bunk
with my daughter who was having trouble
sleeping last night and I got the text
and I thought oh um a day off I can try
to catch up on some things but I also um
knew from a friend about about this
meeting so I I chose to be here um today
I don't teach I advocate and I'm sad
that I have to do that I'm sad that
um there are a lot of teachers there are
thousands of teachers who would probably
want to be here to advocate for their
schools it feels like public schools in
New Hampshire and in this country are
under attack taking away our funding
um uh obviously hurts schools the
teachers and the kids um so
sorry I can't teach today but I am glad
I can be here um so how do vouchers hurt
New Hampshire schools um just a few
quick ideas but I think they undermine
public schools by diverting funding
um are vouchers for you know vouchers
for anyone no um uh income eligib
eligibility limits and this is sort of a
point representative Cornell was
bringing up I was going to say
you know if if someone you know there
are lots of people in my district
probably already going to derfield or St
Paul's or conquer Christian um some of
them are
millionaires why should they get $88,000
or whatever that number is um at the
expense of friends of mine who are
really struggling to make ends meet
taking more property taxes out is going
to make things a lot harder for those
with fixed incomes uh it's going to make
harder it harder for teachers um it
really feels like a bad idea to continue
to hurt um public schools and to to
divert funding um I feel the as a
private school teacher I know special
education students students with IPS
that were moved into my private school
they're they were we were not meeting
their needs we didn't have the Personnel
um I feel like there and I don't know
the details of a lot of this but I do
know um some of the things about
students with IEPs moving into special
ed might not happen um
and the accountability piece um I feel
like is is also missing transparency you
every penny of what goes into public
schools seems to be accounted for but
the Pats Pete SK ski passes horse riding
lessons Costco Amazon I'm very curious
how that is tracked and I doubt that
it's tracked with detail you your time
limit yeah I'll wrap up I'll wrap up um
it's a hard time for schools um our the
state funding in New Hampshire is very
low the $200,000 my school lost this
year because of special education
funding being trimmed back is really
hard um so I'm was curious that you know
as a taxpayer as a parent and as a a
public school teacher um how can we do
better how can we do better to support
public
education at the time it feels like
we're trying we're not trying to do
better it feels like things are going in
the wrong direction thank you thanks any
questions representative kuger thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my uh
question in my experience parents and
teachers alike often provide paper
crayons markers snacks uh Etc to
classrooms is that still the practice
often yeah I probably
spend $200 or $300 a year on school
supplies we ask parents can you please
donate tissues yes we just we sent an
email last week we need more tissues
um food I I often have the top left
drawer on my desk is
snacks I'll give those thank you any
other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you for the
this Peggy van
I've never done this this is kind of
exciting to me welcome thank
you um I am
here basically because I'm I'm fairly
shocked that this bill HB 748 is before
you um I did neglect I'd like to start
off by just introducing myself I'm Peggy
van valkenberg I have um been a proud
educator for over 35 years I'm also very
proud I'm retired now for seven years
and that is a joy to me um I'm from
Peterboro New Hampshire the majority of
my years of teaching actually were in
the conval middle school district and I
there so I am in shock about the the
fact that this bill is before you um
this EFA program feels very unethical to
me be it is taking my tax dollars that
were raised for our public schools and
then we're passing them to families that
are opting to homeschool or tuition at a
private even perhaps a religious school
that may or may not practice
discriminatory
practices I do not want war nor will I
subsidize schools that discriminate
against the majority of New Hampshire
children the majority of New Hampshire
children are educated in our Public
Schools this voucher will do exactly
that this EFA program so yes I was a
proud educator in the new hampsh
Hampshire school system I um
was believe me believe me there was any
money that we needed to expend in New
Hampshire was always incredibly tight
yeah if I determined that um we needed
to purchase a new set of microscopes for
my
classroom I could do that but I had to
do inordinate amount of work making sure
that the the lesson that I was going to
prepare for the students was aligned to
standards common core standards uh goals
for that age level in that child the
group this was a huge part of my job and
a job part of my job I took very
seriously is to identify exactly which
lessons are going to align with those
standards and if purchases needed to be
made that's when you could fill up the
the request but more
importantly more importantly once that
expenditure was made I had to make sure
that learning had occurred so our
students in the New Hampshire public
schools are um their progress is
measured in great
specificity I was always held
accountable for that learning hm how did
they do on the last assessment did that
assessment teach tell us that in fact
that the students had
learned this voucher program or EFA or
LFA has not been tasked they have not
tasked any of the parents to do any of
the above parents are expending my tax
dollars on ski passes pianos gymnast
nastics classes Sports clinics religious
curriculums and they have not been asked
to justify those
expenditures I want to know has learning
occurred do you have proof for that your
your time is up I know here's the last
point I'm going to make this is the
clinker the vouchers the efas are going
to be twice as large as the adequate
educational amount this again is a
discriminatory measure against the New
Hampshire Public School
student again thanks for listening to me
and my thoughts if you have a question
I'm happy to answer thank you
good morning my name is Janet Ward I
live in kukuk New
Hampshire um and given the testimony of
the Prime sponsor representative
verville I want to state that I served
as an aid to a handicapped uh student in
my school district he was one of the
first to be mainstreamed and I also want
to respond to uh something that was said
in terms of calling the public schools
businesses in competition with one
another um local schools are not
monopolies they're not businesses they
are human
institutions sometimes imperfect and if
local schools are not providing all that
is necessary and appropriate then all of
you here should be focusing on working
to improve those schools rather than to
establish uh School
vouches uh so having said that I'll get
to the testimony I prepared for
today I believe it is critically
important to begin our discussion of
House Bill 748 at the beginning it was
Thomas Jefferson who initially offered
the idea of public schools paid for by
local taxes to the Virginia
legislature why why why did he do this
because Jefferson and other founding
fathers realized that in a Democratic
Republic it was essential that citizens
be able to read about understand and
discuss common concerns and to frame and
support wise legislation regarding their
shared
concerns the founders were always most
concerned with what they called
factions factions were decide defined by
James Madison in The Federalist Papers
number
10 I quote by a faction I understand a
number of citizens who are united and
actuated by some common impulse impulse
of passion or interest adverse to the
rights of other citizens or to the
permanent and aggregate interests of the
community end of
quotation those who support House Bill
why because House Bill 748 would force
New Hampshire taxpayers to provide tax
dollars to parents or Guardians who wish
to use those dollars in private
religious or homeschooling situations
and this is the key over which the
taxpayers have little
oversight House Bill
748 would force taxpayers to pay for a
private good not a public good all
School vouchers
represent taxation without
representation House Bill 748 is yet
another unconstitutional Demand on New
Hampshire taxpayers and I respectfully
request that you do not support this
you any questions per
Hall thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question sure uh the the
prime sponsor started out by saying that
a private education is a public
education yes or no no thank you no and
if I may I went to public schools and
then because I had an older cousin who I
adored um who was going to a a high
school a religious high school and she
wore a uniform I beg my my parents to
please please send me where Coro went
so they couldn't afford it but my
grandmother seeing how desperate I was
said of course you know I'll I'll help
and so I did go to that high school got
a good education but it was a good deal
of of it was religious and
um I must be very clear I
support and admire um religious beliefs
and thankfully we live in a nation where
everyone is free to have the religious
beliefs um they they wish to have but um
Randall Balmer a professor of religion
at Dartmouth College has written a book
called solemn reverence the separation
of church and state and American life
and um this public dollars being given
to parents or Guardians and then being
spent on religious schools is is
unconstitutional so I thank you for
listening thank you representative
Murray thank you madam chair um thanks
for taking my question and this sort of
goes along I I'm curious to know um
whether or not you share any concerns um
around um the scholarship organization
itself on line one on page six is noted
to be able to accept gifts and grants
from any source to cover administrative
costs to inform the public about EFA
programs or to fund additional efas so
my question to you is um given that uh
your recent conversation of separation
of church and state and any other sort
of Grant uh uh givers do you share any
concerns that there could it doesn't say
how much uh information or how much
money could be spent on Administration
cost versus um um public uh EFA sort of
public information campaigns versus the
actual education of students so do you
share any concerns around that yes I do
and I had a private conversation
with um commissioner edelblute in
2019 and after an hour of conversation
uh Frank and I
uh had you know discussed many things
and he stood up to Signal the end of the
conversation and he said Janet you and I
agree on a lot of things but one thing
you you and I do not agree on is I
believe public money should pay for
private education and you don't
and that's absolutely clear I don't
understand why I uh a
taxpayer um should be required to pay
for private educational situations over
which I have virtually no control um
this to me uh as Randall balber uh made
clear in in his book and uh it is made
very clear in a book called The
privateers
unconstitutional any other questions
representative Freeman thank you madam
chair and thank you Miss wood for coming
in front of us so I have a question um
about you stating as a taxpayer you
shouldn't have to pay for it um are
parents not also taxpayers parents who
utilize thefa program of course they are
yes and
um I repeat I respect the right of
parents to um have the religious beliefs
they do to you know educate their
children in the way they think is best
but in public schools I can attend and I
do um the school board
meetings and I can call the school and
ask the principal or even visit the
superintendent which I have done so that
I can walk into a classroom with
permission and without disturbing the
teacher of the class and see what is
happening see what is being taught I can
read the textbooks I know what I'm
paying for but the school voucher money
yeah I do not know what I'm paying
for representative drive thank you and
thank you for Ching my question I'm
confused about your term voucher because
do not know that the voucher program was
1988 clarify what you're telling me
please um there is no Voucher Program
specifically that uses the word voucher
it is you telling me that because they
call it an education Freedom account
it's not a
voucher I guess I would ask you what
your definition of a voucher is uh money
given to a parent or a guardian for
follow follow up okay I I guess we
differ in our definition of a voucher
because I would consider it much more
specific to a a service or something
that it would provide rather than
educational is that not your
understanding I have no idea what you're
describing to me I'm I'm working hard to
understand could you could you clarify
it yeah sure thank you all right I'm I'm
defining a voucher as a specific item to
give to someone for a specific item to
purchase or use and I I don't consider
for an educational program a specific
thing there are lots of specificities
involved in that but it's not a specific
voucher for a specific thing you're
giving money in an educational Freedom
account to an account for the people who
are are getting that money to spend as
they wish within the guidelines that
they're given so I'm just asking do you
think that you're giving us a voucher
for a specific thing when you say is a
voucher
program well certainly it's for
educational purposes is that are we both
agreed on
that yes but ites and a voucher are both
as I understand it and as you understand
it money given from public
taxes to parents or Guardians for
educational purposes is that
correct I would say that that was my
definition of Education Freedom account
and I don't want to get into it but
we can I would love to discuss this with
I would very much like to talk to you
represent and um I also strongly
recommend the book the private
teers thank you thank you oh well are
you willing to take another question yes
of
course thank you I appreciate you taking
my question your closing statement was
about taxation without representation
and that point is well taking my
question to you is is the opposite also
true if there is a parent with their
student in a private District if they're
still paying taxes to the public
District I you also mentioned that you
were able to go into the school to see
what is taught in the classroom I
imagine a parent who pays taxes in that
District doesn't have students in that
District probably wouldn't be giving the
same ability and probably for good
reason so wouldn't that also be taxation
without representation into that school
district I would be very surprised if a
parent from any District wanted to visit
a school in a different district and
made a respectful request that they
would be
denied also um a few years back I had uh
an experience at a State Board of
Education meeting where a parent was
very very upset that their school
district did not offer swimming uh a
swimming program for their son um and
this parent said that their son had a
special talent etc etc and um you she
she felt that she should be allowed to
have money to go into a private
situation and the recommendation was
made that perhaps the child could be
taken to with permission to another
school that had a swimming program um so
what I'm suggesting
is are the public schools perfect no no
Human Institution is perfect our New
Hampshire schools pretty dar good yes
yes I think they are and I think there
are lots of opportunities for a body
like this to identify areas in specific
schools or maybe generally where
improvements could be made and the
amount of time that this body has been
spending on the voucher program uh or
the EA program taking their attention
away from improving Public Schools makes
me very sad thank you representative
Murray this will be our last question
thank you madam chair um would you not
say that there is representation at the
local um Public School level for any
taxpayer who wants to walk into a public
school board meeting during the public
hearing and public comment opportunity
to present questions to the duly elected
board that is there before them it
happens all the time I was just there
and um there were lots of how shall I
put this um there was a lot of variety
in the comments
made and there was a wonderful
respectful
atmosphere and um although not everyone
in the room agreed with everything um
there was a sense that we were all being
respectfully heard and that's what I'm
feeling right now here and that's a very
thank you very much I put down two
minutes I may take the three so set the
alarm I'll set it my name is Sally Kelly
I am from triester Hampshire I served in
our legislature for six years
representing Chichester and Pembrook I
had not planned on testifying today I
came at the total last minute when a
friend called me but I'm sitting here
and I'm sitting here as a taxpayer
and a citizen of our great state and my
great town and also Pittsfield which is
part of our
district I currently serve as our school
moderator what that means is this
Saturday at our town meeting I will be
our town sorry our town School District
meeting I will be facilitating that
meeting and in that role I have attended
many School Board board meetings this
fall and listening to the budget and
trying to figure out where the cuts come
from and how many teachers we have to
cut what programs we need to combine
what extracurricular do we need to get
rid of and I'm sitting here listening to
this in a state where we all know we
rank number 50 in the United States for
in terms of how much our state funds our
public education and now we're adding
more cost onto the town I understand
it's enabling but why are we even
talking about it we need to be talking
about how to better fund our Public
Schools not take additional money away
thank you and I think I made it under
the three way under
good any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
David
Trumble thank you madam chairwoman and
committee members my name is
excuse me my name is David Trumble I'm
from the town of where I oppose this
bill for two reasons first I think that
it is
unconstitutional I'll go back to the
prime sponsor's first words she said
each local community has an obligation
to educate all children that's not
correct in New Hampshire it is the
state's obligation to provide education
for all the children first of all in the
Claremont one case they said we hold
article 83 imposes a duty on the state
to provide a constitutionally adequate
education to every child and they cited
all the way back to Governor Wentworth
in 1771 who said that it was the duty to
educate remained with the state he they
cited this the house and the senate in
1795 for the same point it's the state's
job this bill is based on a completely
false premise that it's the local Town's
job to educate children it is the
state's job and that's under our
Constitution and our Supreme Court the
second thing that the prime sponsor said
is that public education can play take
place in a lot of different locations
that also goes against New Hampshire
Constitution Article 83 in its own
language specifically says public
schools in the Claremont case it said
that duty to educate every educable
child in the public schools it's the
Constitutional duty of the state to fund
the public schools this is kind of
fanfiction version of New Hampshire
history this bill it's not the town's
job to educate and it's not our job as a
state to educate in the private schools
that's an optional idea it is not
required the other reason I object to
this bill is I think it would hurt the
local schools and the question was well
how will it hurt them where's going to
be the loss of money if it's only
$88,500 per
student there's a few ways it'll drain
funds from the local schools first is
the 50% that they that is paid for by
the state that's the 80 the four first
$4,200 the bill assumes in the financial
statement that the money will be
reimbursed by the state that is based on
the myth that the town will save funds
from students who switch from public
schools to private schools as of
November of 2024 according to the
Department of Education there's only
493 switchers from public to private
schools under the EFA program with 500
public schools in New Hampshire that's
less than one switcher per School how
can a public school save any money if
they're only having one child switch
you're not going to fire any teachers
any pairs none of your expenses go down
the second way you're going to lose
money at the town is you have to match
that 4,200 with your own 50% that will
be a complete loss coming out of the
local District's money the bill
essentially uses the money in the public
schools as an ATM machine to finance the
non-public schools third families who
are planning to send their child to a
private school anyway can still get
$10,000 per 8,000 to 10,000 depending on
how the bill actually is interpreted
that money will be lost to the town I'd
like to just finish up brief May uh the
town is also liable even if they resend
this to pay for that child all the way
through till they graduate so that child
will cost them 8 to 10,000 year one by
12 years it's $100,000 per child if you
have 10 children doing it in a town
that's a million dollars that town loses
the last thing is that the town will
have to Def find endless lawsuits over
whether funds are available the bill
does not give the superintendent the
power to determine the potential
long-term costs as part of whether or
not there's any money available now so
in other words if the town says oh we
have $10,000 will do one EFA if they
then resend it they're still on the hook
for 10 more years that's $100,000
expense the bill does it's got eight
pages it doesn't even address the
question of what superintendent can use
in making that determination long-term
expenses will be hurt that means fired
teachers less peras less reading
Specialists it's going to hurt your
local schools that's how it's going to
hurt your local school thank you thank
you um representative Murray thank you
madam chair thanks for taking my
question one of the questions that I am
curious about is whether or not you see
there being any potential confusion for
um you talked about funding being
available or not in the event that the
scholarship organization claw back
funding after giving it um then uh who's
on the hook for that is that the state
or is that the Local District if the
money was there and then is maybe taken
back and said oh we act we this is not a
qualified expense and they claw the
money
back that that's that's another good
question I don't know how it would work
in that regard um my my I agree with
that and my initial concern is just how
does the superintendent set a number on
July 14th do they say well we have
$10,000 extra dollar how many schools
have $10,000 extra dollars but if they
say we have 10,000 we'll do one EFA but
if then this the school the town the
next year votes they say oh we're losing
money here they've shut it off they're
still on the hook for every child they
put up in year one for 10 more years so
can the superintendent look at that
long-term expense and say I'm not going
to say yes to one this year because I'm
really saying yes to one for 10 years
and therefore the superintendent says no
the bill doesn't clarify there's going
to be lawsuits in every single town as
to how this is determined that's an
expense the towns will have to to pay
because of a bill that doesn't explain
you
Jack
okay
good hi I'm a resident of marac and uh
just a
person that works for a living and took
some vacation time
to to speak on something important to
me so I support school choice the
existing EFA laws and the other proposed
legislation to expand them I actually
believe the best approach is local efas
because it's a natural place to fund
education and this bill could replace
all the
others the problem with the current
situation is that it's not full
replacement
cost so the the parents have to come up
with when they're already taxed they
have to come up with some of the money
to make the choice to go to a private
school and the secondary problem is that
the state needs to raise revenue to fund
these
efas uh the solution is local efas cuz
the funding is already available the
cities and the towns are already
collecting the property taxes for the
schools and if I use the numbers from
the town of marac we have a school
budget of 93 million under 3600 students
and the round numbers are that that's
over 25,000 per student so we have
plenty of money to fund our
schools now I look at just a few this is
absolutely not an endorsement of these
schools just three that I found from the
uh from the State website list Dairy
Field in uh Manchester is grade 6 to 12
that's about 26,000 that would be break
even with the cost of the public school
you have Trinity High School in
Manchester under
15,000 you have Bedford Academy A K
14,000 so we have the problem that town
budgets and and Marx Town budget the
schools the public schools are 2third of
the Town budget uh we have an
opportunity to significantly reduce
property
taxes um the
town's uh decreased payments to school
districts uh I mean I I'm I'm actually
talking more to the ideal here than to
the specifics of this bill because I
think the specifics of the bill are
still with its hands tied behind it back
of what it could
be essentially you've got
$26,000 you could hand everyone of a
flat fee of 20,000 and not check who
paid on Amazon for what or whether it
was Pat's Peak or not and the taxpayers
are winning if those parents are happy
that their child's getting educated and
they got $20,000 and no one ever looked
at that that would be fine um it could
include homeschooling uh the state
infrastructure for the FAS can stay to
to manage all of this and just the
closing points are your property taxes
too high do you support school choice
solve both problems at once support
local
efas thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you Mary wilky
[Music]
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is Mary wilky I'm a
retired public school teacher and I live
in conquered um I um have many reasons
to dislike vouchers altogether the whole
idea of vouchers I'm not going to talk
about those today because uh I've talked
about them many other times but um I
would like to address flaws in this
specific uh proposal legislation first
of all I I know it's an opt-in program
but if you look at the required language
in the warrant article it's uh it
wouldn't help the average person
understand what's going on here it says
you know you have to um say shall we
adopt the provisions of this bill to
allow establishment of a local education
Freedom account program in our district
well it doesn't say anything about who's
paying for it it doesn't say that your
taxes might go up um I think it needs to
be a lot more clear than that I I
believe it would be misleading and
meanwhile
we can foresee that um well-healed Pro
voucher out ofate lobbyists will be
there sending their cards putting their
flyers in people's mailboxes Etc and um
people may vote for this not realizing
how it will affect them um oversight of
the scholarship organization in this
bill is even less uh credible than in
the current EFA program uh at least
under the current program there's a
legislative oversight committee that
meets and can ask the uh commissioner
and the head of the scholarship
organization to come and answer
questions not in this one nobody that I
can see has any um oversight and in fact
in the fiscal note it says that the
department has not identified any state
administrative cost Dev to this program
so I'm assuming they're not planning to
spend much time overseeing this either
uh meanwhile the scholarship
organization is given total immunity
total immunity from liability in
handling these funds which means they're
not required
which means they're not required to use
even um reasonable care which is the
legal standard we don't we're not going
to ask them to use reasonable care as
they handle millions of dollars
potentially of taxpayer funds um as
others have mentioned there's no
transparency the school district me
property tax rers will know nothing
about what's going on in the schools and
the programs with these uh funded here
um there's no prohibitions on
self-dealing parents could pay their
relatives to tutor their kids no cap on
how what the hourly rate might be
employees of the scholarship
organization could set up their own
little Learning Centers and maybe funnel
people in that direction there's no
prohibitions on those um the language on
special ed services is very insufficient
other people have mentioned that I mean
far as I could tell it says it says um
that uh that the scholarship
organization has to tell EFA parents
that the student students can receive
special ed services in their District
but it doesn't ever say that students
can receive special ed services in their
District I it should be spelled out
clearly people recognized a lot of
confusion around that and um one more
thing um the scholarship organization
gets 10 up to 10% as they do in the
current program the current program has
an average EFA that's half the EFA of
this new proposed program meaning
they're going to get twice as much money
if they get 10% twice as much money for
doing the same work and um that seems
unreasonable to me as a taxpayer I have
prepared for you a line by line because
there are so many flaws and
inconsistencies and gaps in this bill
it's four pages of line by line going
through the bill and I'm sorry that
you're exing on it today when the online
portal won't even be closed yet but um
and you probably won't have time to look
at my line by line but I'm submitting it
for the record and would like you to
know that more than 2600 2600 people
have already signed in opposed 244 and
the number would continue to rise except
it won't make any sense once you've
already exacted at 1:00 thank you thank
you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much excuse me Madam
chair um representative Hall
representative litfield and I have a
subcommittee meeting at 11:00 yes room
203 on the cell phone
thanks
Caitlyn
berer I'm sorry about that no no worries
go good morning honorable chairperson
and members of the education policy
committee thank you for taking the time
to listen to My Testimony today I live
in marac and am here today in opposition
of HB
748 I am here as a parent of two
students uh that are in our public
education and also as a member of our
School District budget committee um so I
have spent a lot of time looking at a
lot of numbers and I can tell you that
it would have a big impact on us um so
first uh as I was listening to the uh
Prime sponsor I kind of wrote down a
couple other things um I wanted to
address where um he had spoken about how
it wasn't double dipping um but it would
be double dipping in that you requesting
the services special ed services still
be provided Ed in the school or provided
for the student which is a cost to the
school district um we already aren't
getting the amount of money back from
the state for special education that we
are supposed to get we got
67% um and um that is going to take more
money um away from us uh now you want to
add local EFA cost on top of that the
Statewide EFA uh still exists and we're
taking funds from the education trust
fund that could be used to meet the
state's special education reimbursement
obligations um and instead they're being
used for the efas so we're already not
getting the money that we're supposed to
get for special education and now we're
going to be asking for more money to be
taken out of that budget
for local EFA which which could include
special education which we are going to
still have to have that person in place
at the school even if you don't have um
the student in the school all the time
um my local public school would love to
have a great theater program or a gifted
and talented courses but we can't fund
it at all can't even get the budgets to
pass we're we're stuck with default
budget which means that you remove all
those extra things that you would like
to have a swimming pool would be great a
swim team all those things would be
awesome we can't fund it public
education means that you have to provide
education for everybody and that costs a
lot of money um so uh local efas would
have a negative lasting impact on a
community even if they repealed the
local efas if you look at page 8
starting on line uh 36 it says there
that um you would still have to uh pay
well I think it's 37 it starts talking
about it but that you would still have
to pay for the student to be there until
they are um graduate or 20 years of age
so if in marac right now we have 36
homeschool students um that would be a
minimum of a uh cost that our operating
budget would have to so this would
subtract from our budget a minimum of
288,000 and up to
468,000 just for the students that are
currently homeschooled would have to be
removed from our operating budget which
is already really struggling I know I
got to wrap up sorry I just want to get
to one more Point um where it talked
about on page four line 13 that the
states that the EFA organization would
get to keep 10% annually for who knows
what um school districts can only keep
5% and we have to have public hearings
that tell you exactly what we're using
our money for so it is that is sneaky
suspect and I am not a fan wrapping it
up in marac our town has been working
really hard to improve our school our
students reading and math proficiency
and that costs money money this bill
would take away from our Public Schools
this builds a divide instead of making
the focus on giving our children the
best education that they could have our
school district and Community currently
cannot take on the increased cost that
this bill would place on us I realize
this bill would be a choice local
communities have but it be feels very
sneaky and has a lasting impact a
negative lasting negative Financial
impact on them when the community
realized it's been duped I am in strong
opposition of this bill and the negative
Financial impacts it would cause our
community thank you thank you any
questions
rep representative McDonald okay thank
you madam chair and thank you for your
testimony you mentioned you're a member
of the budget committee if this is a
enabling Bill based on a Citizens
warrant petition Would It Go in front of
the budget committee for a
recommendation and would your
recommendation be on the ballot so if
this was a warrant article it would be
at our deliberative session and they
would have to have it says on their 20
signatures which is five less than you
have to have to have anything else on
our um do a warrant article and the
warrant article would go to the
deliberative session and there somebody
could speak to it hopefully amend it and
then they would be able to put it on the
ballot and then people would be able to
vote from there but the the fact that
you would be putting it on it's not
you're not staying in here they're going
to keep 10% and it's going to cost your
community almost
$500,000 out of your operating budget
just for the students that are on it now
so I mean yes it would be there you
could put it on and say that this is
just local efas but I would be remiss if
I didn't in inform my community what
this would really mean because it
wouldn't just be helping local students
get what they need it would be
negatively impacting their taxes and
increasing their tax burden that they
have because we still have to publicly
educate everybody so you can still have
your money for this and then we still it
still costs the amount of money that it
costs to have the buildings if you had
won 20 what did I say 36 students is not
a lot of students you can't like close
down a building because 36 students
aren't there so you still have to make
up the cost of the other I don't
remember how many students are in our
building our buildings but other lots of
students that are going to have to be
there so it it's a cost to us if I may
just for clarification I appreciate your
comments if I understand you correctly
so the budget committee's recommendation
would or would not appear under the
warrant article um it would not unless
it was brought to us and it was
something that was uh given to us before
the school board had their meeting um
and they present to us the warn articles
from there so it goes Schoolboard
meeting and then our meeting and then if
it has a financial impact we would speak
about it and vote on it and then our
vote would be on the ballot for you to
see so it would say like the committee
members 13 of us voted zero or yes and z
z for the other or 10 11 one you know
some whatever the numbers are kind thank
you very much yes thank you
representative
Murray thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question I wanted to
clarify you testified to the fact that
you said that the school at the local
public school level administrative fees
you can only um administer or keep 5% of
an administrative fee did I hear you
correctly so we can keep uh the school
district can keep a 5% of like um if you
are well over so say you had a surplus
of money you can keep a percent of that
Surplus after um the budget so you give
all the things to all the people and
then if at the end you're like we have
this extra money you can keep 5% of it
for your uh town and then you have to
have a public hearing about what you're
going to use it on and in our town they
used it on wit and wisdom recently which
is really awesome helping our students
with their comprehension and it cost a
lot of money but that was what they had
to speak about when they're going to um
have that money thank you yes any other
questions see none thank you thank
Wilson uh good morning Madam chair
members of the committee for the record
Becky Wilson from the New Hampshire
school boards Association uh we are
opposed to this bill however um I'm
going to offer some hopefully
clarification or maybe more confusion uh
regarding regarding some of the concerns
that we have and the problematic um
language in this bill
uh in regards to special ed as many of
you know from my previous testimony
previously I served as a special
education director uh here in the state
for a number of years so um some
clarification in terms of some of the
questions that have been brought up or
asked um there are currently already
options now for families or students who
are unhappy with the special education
services that they are getting at their
local District um students or families
could take or apply for the current EFA
program where parents do have to sign
off um and give up their idea rights um
they can send their student to a public
charter school a parent can place their
child there um there is unilateral
parental placement so outside of both of
those options where parents can place
their children somewhere and then
retroactively try to negotiate some sort
of um appropriate agreement with the
school district regarding that or go to
dispute resolution uh this bill is a
little confusing because it seems like
the school district is going to retain
the cost of the provision of the special
EDR program full-time for all the
students that are attending there uh one
or two students as I think we've already
heard is not going to save the district
any cost there's no cost savings with
that um in addition um these additional
Services of providing uh services for
students who leave to take this EFA
potentially and are coming back to the
school district uh it's a little similar
to the what we currently see with our
Charter School provision of services
where the resident district is retaining
the obligation to provide those services
and I think this committee has heard
numbers of times that that system is not
definitely does not save districts any
money uh if anything it adds costs
because you are uh pulling out sort of
the opportunity for students to get
those services within the context of
their school day currently um so I'm not
I don't know why the district would
agree to or the voters will agree to
this then students are going to
potentially leave but come back to the
district for services that the parent
has taken the funds away to provide um
that doesn't make too much sense to me
in the regards to how this bill is
currently written and I think we've
already seen those challenges this bill
is also written um it seems to be based
on a belief that there is a big
separation between special education
program services and regular Education
Services uh special education and idea
as you all know um is built on the
premise that students require special
education in order to access their reg
regular education program so if they're
not getting their regular education
program in the school district I'm not
sure how the services are benefiting the
child to access the General Ed program
especially when the district has no
oversight potentially of the General Ed
program because the students won't be
there for that um sorry I'll wrap it up
modifications accommodations in a
students IEP this bill seems to state
that the district require is required to
still provide all the IEP team meeting
Services decision making Etc most of the
things a lot of the things in a
student's IEP are on the backs of the
General Ed
teachers accommodations modifications
Etc who's providing those that would be
in the child's IEP and the district
would be responsible for making sure
those things are done but if the
district is not in charge of the child's
General Ed program I'm not sure how you
manage that um there are also some
challenges on the first first page with
the definitions they don't match current
definitions for special education 50% of
the time is considered a full-time
student uh what if the parent enrolls a
child in another Public School who's
responsible for special ed in that
situation um and I know the sponsor of
the bill said it doesn't include the
differentiated aid but but on page six
line 22 it does say that it includes
differentiated Aid so is it twice the
differentiated Aid um anyway I'm happy
to take any questions sorry for the
confusion thank you any questions
representative Murray thank you um
thanks for taking my question when we
talk about cost um we're not just
talking about monetary costs either when
we talk about taking a child out of
their learning day and transporting them
potentially back to a homeschool or a
sending school if you will um to receive
services and then transporting them back
to their other school that's a cost to
the learner as well so I I I I'm
wondering how we um quantify that or do
you share any concerns around that the
memic day loss for the student thank you
for the question representative um I
think this committee has heard recently
on a number of bills a concern that
students are being pulled out of the
General Ed setting or being placed in
some sort of separate setting to get
their special education services um and
the the very um real impact of a lack of
belonging that those students feel um
and that their families are searching
for higher levels of inclusion not less
uh certainly if students are required to
come back to the district to get
services this bill is not written in a
way that helps me understand how an IEP
team would mitigate that situation um I
think we've seen with Charter Schools uh
busing students back and forth for
services not only is it costly
financially from a fiscal standpoint but
the day is very much interrupted um I
don't know how you would bring a student
back and forth for really highly
inclusive Services if the student the
whole point of that is that they are
included so you would have to segregate
those services to some extent uh
certainly that would be a concern um and
in terms of you know having access to
the least restrictive environment with
your peers I'm not sure how that gets
vetted out in the context of this
bill follow upk you madam chair and then
with regard to um it being the parents
fiscal responsibility to transport the
child whether it's a you know a special
modality of a bus or something like that
my question then is do you do you share
any concern that they might not even
pursue the services if that is an undue
burden to them that they
cannot figure out thank you for the
question representative
um to to answer your question that's
always a concern however the way this
bill is written I believe if specialized
transportation is in the child's IEP to
access their services the district would
have to provide it so even though the
sponsor of this bill says it doesn't
include Transportation I think the
district would be on the the hook to
provide it same with par professional
support I'm not sure if a par
professional was in a child's IEP
because they need that to access their
educational environment even if the
parent enrolls the child in a private
school for example if the par
professional is in the students IEP I
think the district at some level there
would need to be a some sort of
mitigation of how you're going to handle
that situation um who's overseeing the
pair professional is it the private
school are they hiring them and
reimbursing the district is reimbursing
there's a lot of questions and concerns
about that um and I think again we've
heard that there are private schools for
students who are in the current EFA
program where students and families have
given up their idea rights but who
choose not to take students based on the
intensity of their needs um would this
bill the way that it's written sort of
give private schools the idea that a
student could sort of be enrolled in a
private school and should of shut off
their needs so to speak during the
school day but then have to be going
back to get Services that's not
typically how disability work to be
perfectly honest um and I think I would
have some concerns about the perception
that you can separate out a child's
needs for certain hours of the school
day that if you're really doing a good
job finding students eligible for
special ed it's because they need it
throughout their school day thank you
you're welcome representative wock thank
you madam chair uh thank you for taking
my question U I've been very impressed
with the the so far with your dialogue
regarding some of the issues that
generated uh from your research what
concerns me is believe it or not we're
supposedly supposed to exec this bill
this afternoon so I so uh which is
almost clearly
unconscionable uh that being said if I
may are there any other modifications
that you have there that we need to hear
now because we now we're going to be
trying to make a decision on this I'd
appreciate that input uh thank you for
the question representative Woodcock
there I mean again I think you could go
line by line in this bill it's very
lengthy it doesn't necessarily I I
haven't done a side by side with the
current EFA program to see where there
are substantial differences but there
are substantial differences it doesn't
necessarily line up with our charter
school rules or statutes in terms of how
things are provided um there are
problems with both already I think it
would take some time to kind of go
through this and figure out really what
are the
impacts the other couple of things that
are just very obvious um the current EFA
program says that if ever that program
is discontinued that students who are in
it now will be eligible until they
graduate high school or until they age
out of special education which for some
students is at age 22 I don't know what
happens in this bill with that um this
says that you're only eligible up to age
20 but specialed students could be
eligible till age 22 so this doesn't
really line up with that um it doesn't
is it just when they get a regular
education diploma that's concerning to
me um I don't know how an IEP team is
going
to do that their work with Fidelity
given the fact that the the parent to no
no you
know conflict with the parent but the
parent is going to make what decisions
they think are best for their child's
education experience the district has no
oversight of that so to try it just is
very confusing about how that's going to
work who's responsible for making sure
the child's making progress on their IEP
goals if their IEP goals are tied to the
curriculum and you don't have any
oversight of the curriculum um you know
and and again I I understand that the
intention is to try to provide families
with additional funding to go do these
things but it's not it's going to cost
the district more money the district is
going to have to run that program plus
Charter Schools plus this other program
and while I certainly respect the voter
will um as a Schoolboard
Association not every unless you have
some really in-depth knowledge or you
are a parent of a student with a
disability I'm not sure that you really
understand exactly what you are offering
with this program and sort of the
unintentional cost that could come along
with that thank you you're welcome thank
you madam chair any other
questions see none thank you thank you
madam
my uh good morning chairman noo and
members of the House Education policy
committee uh my name is Deborah H I am
president of the American Federation of
teachers New Hampshire and I am here on
behalf of our 3500 members across the
state to oppose HB 748 um every student
in the grand state has a constitutional
right to a robust public education that
means an education with um well- Tred
teachers and Par Educators who can give
them support in the classroom and make
sure that they are learning and having
their academic needs Meed met sorry and
um this bill if passed would make that
so much harder because state is not
meaning its obligation to make sure that
every district is funded so that they
can um provide this opportunity for a
robust public education many of our
districts are already struggling with
their budgets and placing a huge burden
on local property taxpayers to the point
where they have already cut back on
Services they have High um student to
teer ratios not a lot of support staff
already if you pass this you're are
going to have situations where you're
setting
up in a
district an expectation that you will
have local school
vouchers and that money has to come from
somewhere and that's the
problem you will have a cost of between
$836 and
$3,668 per student that has to come out
of the local budget I understand some of
it comes back from the state eventually
somehow it's a little bit clear uh on
whether it's you know paid forward or
has to be paid out front by the local uh
and gets reimbursed from the state but
that money has to be available it has to
be in the budget and um local taxpayers
might not know that when they're voting
on this because the warrant article
doesn't make the consequences
clear it just says oh we're going to
help kids so that you know parents can
make the choice that they think is best
for their their student great that would
be nice but most parents want students
in a well-funded
robust public education in their local
public school we know that um so the
consequences you're going to be forcing
local districts to either raise local
property taxes or make deep Cuts in
their public schools because we know
most of the students using vouchers on
the state level already are students who
were not in the public schools you're
not going to have many students leaving
voucher this um um bill says that the
students eligible will be charter school
students I understand they're Public
Schools but they're not traditional
Public Schools you're not budgeting for
them in your school budget there'll be
um
homeschoolers private school is excluded
if they're already enrolled in private
school um I went through and I looked on
the State website for some of the places
where you have home schoolers who are
the responsibility of local
districts in the M Regional School
District there's 223 resident
homeschoolers if this passes their
budget will have to include 1.8 million
to cover the potential cost of local
vouchers at just twice the um base per
pupil aid over 300 over 3 million if
they get all the differential Aid
Nashville School District 161 resident
homeschoolers
1.3 oh I'm sorry I misread mic is 1.8
million natural school district is 1.3
million um or 2.2 million if they get
all the differential Aid Dairy
Cooperative School District
18,000 and uh and then $847,000 at the
top end if it has all the different you
have to have this built into your School
District budget so you're ready to fund
those vouchers and when or if the state
reimburses you for that base pupil Aid
and how much you're going to get are you
sure you're going to get it again
there's a little bit on un clear so you
have to be ready to have that all to
go wrapping up okay so wrapping up um we
know that most Granite State families
want their kids in a well-resourced
robust public education Public School in
their local neighborhood school a school
where they can go to the school board
and have their voice heard and have a
say in how it's run uh 78% of New
Hampshire voters in a poll in January
robber research said they want to see
tax money used to strengthen Public
Schools not on vouchers we urge you to
find HP 748 in expedient to legislate
thank you thank you and I do have this
to hand around okay representative
Murray thank you madam chair um thank
you for taking my question on page four
starting on line 18 where it's like sub
5A yep it says the scholarship
organization shall not Adopt A system
that relies this is enumerating
Authority and responsibilities of
scholarship organizations says the
scholarship organization shall not Adopt
A system that relies exclusively on
requiring parents to be reimbursed for
out of pocket expenses but rather shall
provide maximum flexibility to parents
by facilitating quote direct payments to
Education Service Providers uh my
question to you is whether or not um
there could be confusion in in in the
EFA wallet dispersement and then also
funds provided uh direct to provider um
services that may uh you might end up
potentially over overpaying the account
because you have a certain amount in the
my class wallet and then you're the way
I'm reading this uh sending direct
payments to
providers that does sound unclear it
sounds like perhaps you could end up
with double payments
um and that would definitely be
something that you would want to make
sure there was strict oversight because
this is after all taxpayer money and
again you're going to have to go back to
your local property taxpayers and ask
for more money cu you
those let me find my numbers again those
223 resident homeschooled students in
the mic Regional School District you
hadn't budgeted anything for and now
you're going to have to have a line item
in your school budget to fund the
potential of having a local vure for
each of
them so you either going to have to
raise taxes or find the place to cut
that out of your budget that's a lot of
classroom teachers or Paris or you don't
have that much of materials you can get
rid of represent and your kids in your
school are going to have to do with
less representative dry thank you and
question why are you putting in a line
for every home schooler assuming that
they would be students of
lefas that is The Prudent way to budget
when you do your household bills and you
write 10 checks do you assume seven of
them won't be
cashed you you'd have your account you
know in the in the red follow up thank
now do you budget for all homeschoolers
coming back to school now whether
regardless of whether they have you have
not you're creating a program that says
sign up for
expenses doesn't it make prudent sense
to plan for a large number of people to
take advantage of
that wouldn't you be irresponsible not
to shortsightedness is why our schools
any other
you
okay good morning my name is Heather
Barker and I work with nhsaa here in
conquered I am the student service
director there and like Miss Wilson I
was a district specialed director in
marac
actually I actually am not going to
repeat any of the things that other
folks said here this
morning I do believe in school choice
I've said that before here it is not
prudent though for local communities to
Bear the brunt of paying for the public
education in New Hampshire and the
special education of New Hampshire and
in addition to that Charter education
EFA education and now local EFA
education until the state assumes the
responsibility to actually fund the
public education and special education
once we do that and we take on that
obligation as a state we can have these
things that we should be able to think
about each child and what is in the best
interest of them it's an honorable it's
an thing you guys are trying to do at
the same time we're breaking it over the
backs of the local towns who are now
rising up against their schools because
it costs so much to educate the children
to pay for the special
education just the line in here okay on
page eight there's line 13 and 14 is it
for special educ ation we've now put it
in here and again it's honorable that he
brought this idea forward that you know
and that you know people should be able
to send their kids where they want to
yes I I hear that and to state that we
already do it in special education kids
go to private schools hey that's Along
by law the Continuum of special ed
services and those are decisions that
are difficult to make as we move
children further and further away from
their local community SCH school right
their T their peers their typical peers
in those settings that's done through
the special ed process those are not
private schools for Choice okay that's
the special ed process the idea that we
aren't going to be obligated as
communities to provide fape the town
will have to do that if the IEP says
Transportation we're
transporting if it says I mean there's
nothing here that says the parents
signing off that they're not going to
receive that what it says is and I I get
it that was honorable that his the the
sponsor of the bill that spoke this
morning talked about the idea that he
does understand the cost that's going to
the local community when we put the
obligation on the public school to fund
what's happening in a charter school or
any other place and again I believe in
having those options absolutely but
until the state of New Hampshire funds
the general education and special
education so that not all of of this
like so much of it sits in your local
towns which is why there is no so much
dissent at this point and that's too bad
got thank you very much
questions great s thank
you is there anybody else who wishes to
speak on the
bill okay we're going to close the
hearing on HB 748 and we're going to
take about five minute break before we
hearing
e
minutes
righty we're going to open the hearing
on HB
752 relative to procedures for the
closing of a charter school and I
welcome the prime sponsor representative
cordelli thank you very much uh for the
record Glenn cordelli representing
tufton burough wolf burough and oy in
the beautiful Lakes Region and uh this
bill is a result of conversation with
the Department of
Education um there is uh an existing
statute um relative to Charter
revocation and
probation um there have been um a a
couple of instances in the past few
years
when um the department thought that they
um if they had additional tools
available to them it might help them in
remedying the situation one way or the
other um in relation to a charter school
um that was having
problems so this is the result of that
um and you can see uh I'll just go
through a few of the highlights on this
um
in the first section starting on lines
four and five it outlines um eight or
nine um uh Provisions
circumstances where the uh state board
could revoke a charter prior to the
expiration um and you'll see those there
um you know one of the most common would
be uh the school is uh financially
unstable
um then down on Roman 2 line
19 uh the uh state
board um could accept um petitions from
parents of current students or by the um
uh Board of u a district uh to uh have
the uh Charter
revoked uh and then on Roman 3 following
that the State Board before acting on
that petition would have to check with
the uh Board of Trustees of that charter
school and see about a um remediation
plan for the
situation um that is carried on in in
Roman 4 at the bottom of the
page
um then importantly on the next page in
Roman 5
five um the State Board is given
explicit uh provision to immediately
revoke a charter school um Charter uh if
there are uh situations which U would uh
risk the harm of students so that's an
important
provision um the there is a second
section of this bill um which is uh
Midway down on line 20 on page two and
that's um the uh what happens to the
records of a closed Charter School um
we've dealt with records for um you know
closing uh universities uh Etc in the
past few years um this outlines uh the
process for uh the records for a closed
charter school and for the Department of
Education uh to be the uh custodian of
those records and spe specifies what
records to be included and
uh excuse me the department making
information available on how someone can
request those
records so um that is the bill in a
nutshell and uh also the intent to give
uh the department uh tools uh that they
feel are necessary for them to uh you
know oversee and monitor uh Charter
Schools who uh might be in uh bad
circumstances thank you thank you any
questions representative
wock thank you madam chair thank you
representative
Celli on line 20 on the you about the
records Rec what happens if I we're
talking um
insolvency basically with the child with
when these child schools
fold if they don't have the money at
that point and some of their records
aren't
electronic and this is requiring
electron all electronic Records who does
that who transposes the written records
in electronic but where did that cost
come from because I'm sure there
application pieces that I'm sure
everything's not all
electronic um yeah it's my understanding
that a lot of these specific type of
Records um would Pro most likely be in
electronic format some of the other
records might not but um the ones that
um we're talking about here uh probably
would be in electronic format okay you
follow me follow okay I I agree with
most of them are but I'm looking at
things like some of the health records
Health notations some dis actions may
not be in a person and student file
um those types of things and they just
right the following few lines there 26
27 I'm not I'm not arguing about the the
bill I'm just saying I'm thinking about
if the school's going under already
who's going to and typically when the we
surprisedly typically when the
department send the bill in they have a
huge physical note for some reason uh so
I'm thinking in this case there' be a
cost somewhere to transcribe get there
that's my only question that I didn't
see anywhere any of the handwritten
records particularly those that that
dealt with maybe health information it
isn't elect I think that if there are um
these types of records that aren't
electronically I think that the uh
Department would take them um and store
them as well um and have them um if
needed by by a student or prior
student okay thank you thank you m chair
representative muray thank you madam
chair um thank you for taking my
question um Mr chairman um one question
that I did have um was with regard to I
think last week we heard a bill similar
on records retention okay and so I was
curious that if if in it like the two
were to proceed forward like um would
they stand in in contradiction to one
another uh or what would we do
potentially because this one seems to
have another caveat to it which is the
actual closure piece um and petitioning
so I'm just curious right um uh my
understanding is that it's the um uh
last in
rules basically um I know that applies
to uh um statutes um because sometimes
we have statutes that are in conflict
and so when that arises it's the last
statute um that takes uh president over
the
other any other
questions represent bbon thank you madam
chairman thank you for taking my
question if if I could just answer that
I'm sorry right um I think that also is
a situation that might be clarified over
um in the uh on the other side of the
house um my question is uh I I can see
that the the bill actually uh repeals
the whole 184 B16 but as I'm looking at
it uh it looks like a lot of the uh
what's in the current one is AED and and
I'm just curious if there are specific
things that you can point to or if
there's a side by side you see what what
is actually being changed by the repeal
and what's being added I I do not have
have a rep um any kind of side by side
um can take a look at doing something
like that yeah I I'm just curious
because it does go into a lot of detail
in the current law so I'm I'm just
trying to figure out what's Chang in so
it's not that I'm opposed to anything
I'm I just try to get the specifics on
that so thank you thank
you any other
you is there anyone who would want to
testify on
752 okay we're going to close the
hearing
is
um
[Music]
um we're just about ready to start with
7 uh house B 763 I just wanted to
mention that um you see rep the
representative changing a sign on the
desk um where the witness sits um that
is so that the camera will pick up what
bill is in progress so someone watching
online um wanting to look for a specific
bill or coming into the middle of things
um they can see what Bill we're
testifying on and if they're looking for
something
um another bill they can always uh fast
forward a little bit so um yeah that's a
uh I think a very good um new process
that we have in place so with that um
we'll open the house session house
committee session on House Bill 763
relative to school emergency plans for
sports related injuries and call on
representative dry thank you thank you
very much Mr chairman and thank you
committee for hearing this uh for the
record I'm representative Margaret dry
from planfield serving the towns of
Charlestown Unity Newport planfield and
Cornish uh a lot of the help from um for
this bill came from the American Heart
Association so I just want to disclose
to you ahead of time that I'm an
instructor trainer for the American
Heart Association but my work is
entirely
volunteer in New Hampshire there are
about 100
200 outof Hospital cardiac arrests every
month according to our own Department of
Safety uh across the United States about
3% of those people who go uh into
cardiac arrest out of Hospital
survive uh in New Hampshire it's
133% and that's largely due to a lot of
the training and CPR and the access to
aeds that we have in the
state next year it will be uh 50 years
since I started teaching C CPR uh I've
seen a lot of changes since then but the
game Cher has been the automatic
external
defibrillator uh CPR circulates
oxygenated blood and keeps brain cells
from dying but the AED in in the right
circumstances can start a heart again
and that's the game
Cher uh House Bill 763 might look
familiar it was SE Senate Bill 379 last
year that talked about plac
aeds especially in accessible places
around schools but it didn't give any
funding for that
mandate this bill starts by answering
some of the questions from last year's
hearings um and then also makes an
appropriation so just go over the bill
one there are italicized versions that
talk about following evidence-based
guidelines um and we listed not just
American Heart Association but any
nationally recognized organization that
focuses on emergency cardiovascular care
just so that there is a National
Standard to to adhere to uh a little bit
later on it talks about not just having
aeds around but somebody trained in
cardiopulmonary solicitation CPR because
that's what really keeps the the person
in a state where an AED might be able to
be effective and um we had a question
last year about if you're using an
athletic field but are not associated
with the school are you still
responsible for that are they
responsible for having a c trained
person or an AED and that's what the
part that says uh on fields or in
competitions in which pupils of the
school are participating so we thought
that that cleared up the questions that
we saw last
year um the appropriation uh it followed
kind of a a a a formula and I'm going to
have somebody else come testify um as
how they arrived at that number and I
just finally want to bring up that
representative George Sykes who I've
worked with in emergency medicine for
decades who was also a co-sponsor uh had
to work today otherwise he would be in
here um voicing his support for this
bill just like I am with that I want to
thank you and I'll be happy to answer
any questions I do have a handout that
shows the department of safety's um
contract that they have with AED
manufacturer that allows citizens and
groups in the in state of New Hampshire
to get reduced prices on aeds so um as
we talk about money this is might be
helpful thank you very much any
questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
very
good morning thank you very much um for
um having this hearing today for the
record I am Nancy vaugh government
relations director for the American
Heart Association in New Hampshire um
and uh I know that uh we want to be able
to get you out for some lunch before you
come back here at 1:00 again to discuss
this bill and some others as well um but
again the American Heart Association as
you can tell is um very much in support
of this policy piece um it is part of
our goal um that by the year 2030 that
we actually double the survival rate
from cardiac arrests um as
representative dry had mentioned um we
have um you know over 200 cardiac
arrests a month um called through 911 so
there there may be more than that um and
uh and the survival rate you know at
about 13% is actually pretty good
nationally it's 100 it's 10% um only 10
that that survive um and for children
which is what this bill is really you
know directed at um it is about a 15%
survival rate across um the country for
cardiac arrest which is still really low
for young people who still have their
lives ahead of them um I am not going to
read you my entire testimony um uh which
um my uh colleague has passed out to you
attached to my testimony though there
are also three letters from advocates
for this policy change um who are also
Healthcare providers and um mothers of
um children who um are in sports and at
least one of them that um has a
cardiovascular um condition from from
birth um so again what I wanted to um to
address was um whatever uh questions
that there may be around the fiscal note
for this um the bill um formula is
really based on a nationwide formula
that um our organ ganization believes
would be about
$3,000 um per school um really
prioritizing first High need schools the
ones who are more financially strapped
um but as again representative dry
alluded to within New Hampshire's
Department of um safety where EMS is
there's a direct purchasing program
where um anyone including schools um can
um obtain an AED for about a third of
the cost what we see nationally um so um
there is is wiggle room um in in the
budget um on this um and again you know
we have um this this is directed at
school schools that have school sports
and um from what I understand um all of
those schools have at least one AED if
not multiple aeds um so we would be
looking at um at helping out those
school districts that um that are again
don't have that many aeds for every
sport event that may be going on
concurrently within their their school
district um so um uh any any amount of
money that we can get for that this year
would be terrific um and again if you uh
do have any any questions I'm more than
happy to to try to give that an answer
um and again you know for this bill the
policy piece is really to make sure that
we emphasize that um a national standard
for using an AED and where to place an
AED
but also the CPR training one does not
need to go through a full-fledged
certified um CPR Course in order to
provide effective CPR but it needs to be
effective to save lives so thank you
very much sure thank you very much any
questions yes represent Cornell Thank
you Mr chair um thank you for taking my
question my question is you say there's
a 15% survival rate for children how
many calls are there for children
fortunately there are not that many um
particularly in New Hampshire so um
again my testimony will will mention
this but of the um 350,000 cardiac
arrests that occur across the country in
young people we're we're looking at
about
23,000 um so it is it is a a lower
number but again it is really something
that strikes suddenly and can be
devastating for for families if that
child doesn't survive yeah thank you
very thank you good afternoon good
afternoon thank thank you for yes Mar
after thank you for taking my question
just just Logistics um I know about last
session on the session before some of us
remember we talked about the 60 seconds
getting there on the back of the little
mobile C and those types of things but
I'm looking at uh specifically on uh
line 19 or actually 24 and through 30
what is what is on page uh one but what
it's talking about is the issue of
having these in every practice ITI venue
uh in sight I'm looking at schools that
have multiple practice venues multiple
fields and the way it's identified now
it it appears to me as I read this that
each site each practice site should have
an
AED um and which which seems
significally different before than we
were talking about the access time to an
ad because if you're in a a grade six
field 6 to 10 middle school high school
there may be seven or eight nine Fields
there so each practice site clearly is
not going to have I don't I don't like
it's yeah let me let me try to address
this so the guidelines that the American
Heart Association you know comes up with
we do this every five years reviewing it
you know looking at the the best case
scenario to get the best outcomes from
cardiac arrests they are looking at that
that AED to be by the side of the person
in Cardiac Arrest within a few minutes
so last year we talked about one to
three minutes which seemed really
regimented um again it is it is within
minutes because every minute that goes
by without having an AED there is less
of a chance of that person being able to
survive so again following the
guidelines that the American Heart
Association develops and that many
organizations use as part of their
training this is discussed and gone over
with people who are obtaining
aeds so follow up thank you so the
so the specificity in the bill which
talks about at each site you though
mention the
guidelines just seems to be kind of
conflicting that's all I understand the
guidelines in the transport but I'm also
looking at which say each each single
site um you have multiple sites in in
you know in the middle schools don't
have a trainer typically they're going
have a radio or every coach have radio
and call back right that's that's it's a
concern and if if the fields are are
situated you know next to one another
that might be one device might be all
that they need in order to get that um
device to this the person if it's a
school district where there's fields
that are in multiple locations yes well
that would be a drive in order to get to
get that Eed to the person so that that
would be the recommendation for for that
scenario would be for an AED to be
there so but this p and exactly it's
exactly what I'm talking about we have
multiple sites over a school area or off
campus yeah that's that's exactly what
I'm talking about this said there must
be an a there because that's um in 25
each each practice I will have them
that's all just look at the logistics of
it I have no problem with the concept
that's all because it's y now you're
looking at a local a local soccer field
five miles away from the school and then
the school has the main things so it
what happens that's y but again this is
really in order to Save a Life you would
need to have an AED within you know
moments of being able to get to that
person okay and it doesn't mean you
can't save the life but I'm just saying
that that yeah that yeah and I may not
understand your question but um but it
is okay thank you R
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in front of us in the event
of a kiac event and an AED is two to
three minutes away can CPI be administ
well this is also part of that
evidence-based training thank you very
much for that question um when
CPR is given without an AED that chance
of survival goes up it should be
effective CPR and so that's where you
may have heard about the you know um the
100 beats per minute that's 100 pushes
on the chest per minute um so this is
where a training or an orientation to
CPR that's not a certified training um
would get to but when you add the AED to
it then you really raise um that that
survival more like doubling the chance
of survival yeah
you're welcome thank
you further questions representative U
Murray thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question and this is just more
of an education piece on my end are
there pediatric AED devices versus adult
ones or are they all programm the same
to to read the heart rhythms yes that
you don't need to have a special a they
they actually do the diagnosing on
whoever the person is in cardiac arrest
and would know what you know yeah great
thank you thank you represent bony thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm just curious it does say um
right at the beginning that it applies
to school districts the governing and
non-public schools but there's nothing
in it in terms of public charter schools
and we've been told oftentimes that if
it doesn't say that it applies to public
charter schools that it should would you
have any objection to including public
we have yeah I'm sorry um yes no we
would have no objection to adding that
my my thinking by saying public would
include Charter Schools but if you're
saying it needs to be more specific
that's not a problem yes thank you so
much see no further questions thank you
very much for being here this morning
and for your uh
testimony and with that we'll close the
session the hearing on House Bill
763 and um we'll break for lunch and
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
going to CAU some more at lunchtime
ourselves
easy I schedule pretty good H you're
I
e
just for everybody's information we're
going to hand out uh to the committee uh
two amendments um for consideration this
afternoon um and then we'll take um a
few minute break while uh one of members
committee
e
okay um believe it or not I think we're
ready for the executive
session that's
correct that's
right um you know we we've stopped the
clock in uh rep's Hall before so
uh you're right
that um we would like to um uh go back
to um house build
384 um there was a
paperwork um glitch um and it never made
it over to the um to the uh clerk's
office so we need to um re
exec uh
384 and and I would call on
representative Noble for a motion this
is a bill to prohibit bullying in
schools I move
second oh I'm sorry yes you're right no
no no it no no this is this is just a
straight revote because it um
never never had y right no we got
confused in another bill where we do
want to
reconsider um so um so the motion is to
itl and is there a second second second
from representative
Woodcock um any further
discussion um
sure so I think we all agreed that um
the section on um child in need of
services maybe went a little bit too far
and that the um bullying officer wasn't
very well
defined
um and it's it is possible that we could
use um some other sections in this bill
to bring into another bullying bill that
we're working
on res Woodcock any discussion CH okay
anything further seeing none um Madame
clerk MO is itl vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes Clerk votes yes
representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonnell yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative
Cornell yes representative Murray yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative Harvey yes
representative kuger yes representative
Snodgrass yes and chairman cordelli yes
yes 18 y zero
Nays thank you very much
um
um did
you
consent okay right
um yeah just showing you uh 763 is on
our list we heard that this morning but
I think that there might um be a
Amendment based on the disc discussion
this morning so we'll hold off on uh
763 uh for the uh sports related
injuries
um House Bill
93 is a school district uh appointment
of a treasur this was to um allow a a
district to change
from an elected position to an appointed
position for the
Treasurer um representative Lichfield do
do I have a motion yes I'd like to make
the motion itl
please is there a second I'll second
that representative Freeman uh any
discussion representa
lville I just simply feel that this is
an anti-liberty bill um as it is now
it's an elected position and I feel that
it should continue to be that
way represent Freeman
thank you Mr chair um I feel these
decisions are better left to the um the
local governments and um it's never a
good idea when the state begins to push
down um these types of edicts so I'd
rather leave it up to the local
government to determine how they want to
committee oh yes represent hul I'm just
thank thank you Mr chair I'm just
curious from what I just heard um
representative if when you say it's up
to the local people does that mean they
can't
appoint it has to be an elected what do
you just a clarification thank you for
the question Representative no not at
all they can determine how they want to
elect res Woodcock thank you chairman um
we had a a
we actually have a Amendment prior to
that by representative lfi and yourself
so
is are we just taking the main motion we
get the amendment
correct thank
you any further discussion
for
e
oh okay uh the motion on the floor is to
itl House Bill
93 I think we're finished with
uh represent Cornell you have a
discussion I do have something to say um
I don't we don't have any problem with
the itl but we're not absolutely 100%
sure that it is okay to just appoint
rather than elect um a Treasurer because
that is why the
the um representative brought in the
bill because they wanted to be able to
appoint rather than elect but we're
still okay with it okay thank
you
good Vice chairman
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative dry votes yes yes
representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald
no representative tenar yes
representative Morris
no representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative
Murray yes representative Woodcock
no representative Hall yes
representative Bon
yes representative Harvey
yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes chairman
cordelli
Nays thank you um Mr chair I'd like to a
Minority Report Minority Report okay
repres and yours
your would be ought to pass correct y do
want
do
no regular
calendar yes that go conent no no uh we
will have a Minority Report from
representative McDonald on no just on
regular calendar okay
yeah yes put this
consent yeah yeah yeah right yeah V
chairman cordelli may I ask you a
question yes learning moment if there if
it's on consent Can it have a majority
and a Minority Report so that's what's
driving it not being on
consent right and I think there's a
question about three being on consent
three in in opposition we
had yeah
okay yes clarification so if there was
two it could go
yeah yes it has to
right
um could the position for report be otpa
with the amendment that was not
presented no yes okay then I oh okay
yeah right okay um I'll wave and put on
okay okay uh
next um let's take a look at uh House
Bill 748 which we heard this morning
accounts
um uh Madame Vice chair could you take
the
gavel I'll open the executive session on
HB 748 establishing a local education
Freedom account program and I Look to
representative cordelli for a motion uh
thank you uh I would move that we retain
house build
748 Sarah
second
second any discussion representative
cordelli um I believe that there was
quite a bit of discussion heard um with
the bill this morning
um and from the part I heard um there
were a lot of questions from um
uh the committee and people testifying
especially uh concerning special
education
um and I think um I'd like to take a
look further at that um and some other
Provisions um and uh that is my reason
for the uh retaining
motion anything from the
second no thank you madam chair any
other
discussion seeing
none Madame clerk the motion is to
retain chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative mcdonal yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
Boni no representative Harvey no
Representative kuger no repres
representative Snodgrass no and chairman
Nays thank
you um House Bill
676 um will take up next um and this was
a bill related to education Freedom
account um advisory Council and several
surveys
um uh this bill um was not sent it was
not processed by the
clerk um we found uh an
error um an Omission on the second page
in that uh when the text was um copy and
pasted from the tax credit scholarship
program um the name was not changed from
education tax credit program to
education Freedom account um and that
should be made so I would like to move
that we
okay second she seconded so I need a
further discussion okay any further
discussion on the uh reconsider motion
okay
uh represent wov has a question okay we
we just have a procedural question so we
would vote on the Recon consider then
we'll vote on the amendment to fix the
bill and then we would vote on the
minute Jen is that U the correct
okay okay so we have have a first and a
second on the reconsider motion any
discussion seeing none Madam clerk
reconsider chairman
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no Representative
balbon no representative Harvey no
Representative kuger no representative
Snodgrass no chairman cordelli yes 10 Ys
eight
Nays um I Look to uh representative
cordelli for a motion
uh thank you um I would like to move uh
ought to pass and then offer an
amendment is there a second second
representative Terry
second representative cordelli uh thank
you um as I indicated there was an error
in um the drafting um or possibly in
what I submitted to the
drafter um and uh I would like to offer
Amendment
discussion am this is on the amendment
yes I'll be voting no on oh sorry M um
I'll be voting no as it doesn't change
anything we're against it and we don't
believe so questions that um should be
in legislation thank
clerk chairman Noble yes representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morse yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no Representative
bbon no representative Harvey no
Representative cluer no representative
Snodgrass no chairman
I Look to uh representative cordelli for
a motion yes I'd like to move ought to
pass with Amendment
0601 it's there second representative
Terry
seconds any other
discussion seeing none Madam clerk the
motion is
otpa Chairman Noble yes representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
mois yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock
representative Hall no representative
bon no representative Harvey no
Representative kuger no representative
Snodgrass no chairman cordelli yes 10 Ys
eight
uh you want to do I'll I'll start it
okay if it's if it's yours yeah free
stre this one do you have another one
that you want to do while
I open the executive session on HB 667
relative to health education and
requiring the viewing of certain videos
demonstrating gestational development
from embryo to fetus through Birth by
public school students and college or
university students and I Look to
representative cordelli for a
motion uh thank you I would like to move
ought to pass and um offer an amendment
is there a
second have more seconds any discussion
thank you I would like to offer
Amendment uh six EXC
15h um which
replaces uh the
bill with uh the text in the
amendment
um I think that there were uh problems
with the original uh original bill in
terms of um a specific video being
defined
in relation
to uh the um College systems being
involved and the Attorney General uh
being
involved um this
simplifies things by repeating much of
what is in uh statute and rules related
to the health curriculum and in the
standards uh that the curriculum shall
be age appropriate and medically
accurate
it um it should
provide information on abstinence
adoption healthy relationships and human
growth and development and include a
high include a presentation of high
quality computer generated animation or
ultrasound video that shows the
development of the heart brain and other
vital organs in the early fetal
development um I think it's important um
in terms of health and uh sexual
education uh to see the development of
um
uh with uh um my uh grandson um born
missing part of his heart it was um very
interesting to talk with the surgeons
and all about um development and the
development of the heart and look and
see um why um one chamber of his heart
uh never
developed
um so I I think that
um it's important uh to see this um but
I also feel it inappropriate to specify
the name of any one particular
I can agree with pretty much everything
that chairman cordelli mentioned um my
only disagreement would be the single
comment of a fetus for instance because
to me it's a human life so seeing the
development of a baby developing within
a womb
is to me
important any other discussion
representative
wock thank you madam chair I um
I appreciate the the amendment um by
represent cordelli in trying to make a
bad Bill less bad but I I I I am con I
am concerned that uh we are dictating to
Local Schools exactly what they already
know now which is they have a health uh
curriculum that's taught by professional
trained people they make up the
curriculum these parts are covered
between biology and the health education
program who are the professionals and
for us to start speculate and spec me
specify uh videos even though we didn't
identify um a particular
video the other part of this I
understand we went into the the
automated U characteristic recording but
there still allows for the video
recording uh which was beyond that so I
I just think this pill is is um Way
Beyond way beyond our scope of of
authority uh and we shouldn't be
dictating local curricula
discussion can go right we want to call
for one second sure
okay
[Music]
okay was there any other
discussion
okay so we have a motion of OTP for the
amendment this clarification Mr we're
voting on now right just the amendment
thank
you chairman Noble yes representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative
Murray yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balon yes representative Harvey yes
representative kuger yes representative
Snodgrass yes and chairman cordelli yes
18 y zero Nays consent oh I
mean
don't representative cordelli do you
have a motion uh yes I would like to
move on to pass with Amendment uh 0
0615 h0 second representative morrris
any
discussion no representative Corell
thank you madam chair um I'm I'm going
to be voting no on the bill even though
the amendment does make the bill better
I I still don't think we should be um
dictating to districts what they should
be teaching in their classes um and I
just it makes a bad Bill better but it's
still I don't agree with the bill
discussion
yes okay Madame clerk we have a a motion
for
otpa chairman Noel yes representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no Representative
balbon no representative Harvey no
Representative kuger no representative
Snodgrass no and chairman cordelli yes p
uh let's next move to House Bill 752
that we also heard this morning which
school represent did you have a motion
on this Bill yes thank you Mr chair um I
know oh um represent Freeman do you have
a discussion on this motion um yes Mr
chair um I I want to pass that well I
don't want to but um I I think this is
really one of those really Common Sense
pieces of
legislation um that will definitely put
some parameters and some rules around
procedures for closing of a chat school
and increasing um transparency as well
as accountability to anything that does
occur around that
closing represent Harry I have nothing
to add I'm in complete agreement with uh
advocacy uh is there any further
discussion representative wood
thank you Mr chair I just want to
reiterate what I did this morning during
the the dialogue uh when it was
presented I have concerns I I appreciate
the fact it's much clearer than it was
before but I do have concerns about the
electronic transport of information when
some of these documents are written by
hand it's not clear how they're going to
get there thank you represent
B thank you um just
clarifications there seems to be typo in
here and I don't think it matters um
actually that's my question it's very
minor if you look on uh page two uh 28
it says the department shall provide
information on its website about how the
request student or personal records I
two and the other question would be it
references the department so I'm
assuming that um somewhere in a prior
paragraph it says that's the Department
of
Education um yes I I think probably the
um enrollment process can change the
word the to
two um and uh yeah generally in the
education statutes um department is
Education any further discussion on
752 seen
per chairman no oh Vice chairman Noble
yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative muray yes representative
Woodcock no representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
Harvey yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes and
chairman cordelli yes 17 y one
nay consent okay
yes
great
just find it cuz I want to make sure I
[Applause]
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 754 FN establishing automatic
Discovery and due process hearings for
actions seeking to enforce special
education rights and I Look to represent
of cordelli for a motion uh thank you uh
I would like to move ought to pass and
uh also offer an amendment then is there
a
second I'll second representative
any discussion uh thank you very much uh
I would like to
offer
uh Amendment
0608 H um and move on to pass on this
amendment um there was a discussion
heard um at the hearing um in particular
by the uh special Leed Advocate um
that uh she thought some of the um
issues and the uh notices that would be
required uh could be made
clearer
um and that
uh she then worked with uh several uh
people who were
here um and uh provided um this language
that I have uh put in into the uh
Amendment uh to make clear about the
information that is to be uh
provided um as you'll see in line 9B it
lists the uh core documents um that
should be provided um as part of a due
process
heing um and the fact that having this
automatically uh happen will speed up
the due process hearings and um make it
clear as to what um parents are entitled
to um and I believe that's the uh the
amendment um and you can see down below
at the end of the page um some of the uh
references um related to this in
amendment well that was on the main
motion
right on the
amendment
okay we did an OTP on the amendment oh
yeah and I did an OTP and then in
any other
discussion representa uh thank you um I
feel that we were given this um
Amendment with very little notice to
really take a deep dive into it there's
several legal references that have been
changed in the document and I don't see
anybody from me that the department of
the special education's advocate here to
ask questions of so I'm wondering if um
the committee would consider holding it
so we could get some of those answers
changes um if if you want to continue on
discussion I believe I had an email from
the special ed director I'll see if I
that so can we hold it and maybe put it
on um another like Wednesday or just to
give a little bit more time so that um
somebody could answer those questions in
person I I don't know if they would be
available in person um but I can uh try
and give you copies of the document the
email from the
director that would be helpful would it
be also okay if we could ask U Becky
Wilson to maybe take a look at the
amendment and give her um uh it's an
executive session but um you know you
know you can show the amendment to Who
You'd
like chair yes I like to back up my uh
associate over here I think that this is
a really complicated piece I looking at
the amendment um you did say there other
people worked on this but she didn't
identify who they were um worked on the
amendment just said those here U so it
appreciative if in fact it was put on
Wednesday's agenda and you requested the
doe to be here so that we could get the
accurate information because this is a
you okay we
um um we will hold off on any further
action on this until Wednesday
um yeah I guess yeah um I will withdraw
my motion on the amendment and the OTP
second I'll second the second needs to
withdraw their motion represent for I'll
withdraw my motion thank
[Laughter]
you yes thank
you
um I think that was
all for today on our executive session
and we are um just
about on time for um House Bill 231
[Music]
minutes and
maybe
right position right so we have three or
four minutes um until we start the
yeah so these middle three we held on to
763 754 and 748 was a retain it's not a
but it is been retained
it went on it went on consent there were
three Nays it was like it was 15 to
three
okay perhaps it did okay uh no the itl
while we're waiting to start the hearing
um uh yeah if we could get the
reports um by the end of the day
tomorrow if that's okay everybody will
um Tuesday yeah I said Wednesday morning
okay um I'm I've been overruled by the
Vice chair um who said Wednesday morning
um so that's that's fine with me also if
uh if we can get them early as possible
because we've got to get them into the
on
right
um was this
one on on the surveys you you did a
um you if you can if you'd like or you
don't have
to
right
e
prohibiting School District Personnel
from transporting students to medical
procedures without parental
consent and uh
Prime sponsor representative Perez is
here welcome thank you thank you
representative cardelli and members of
the committee for the record my name is
representative Christine perz I am from
Rockingham 16 London da and I have
submitted to you a Amendment for this
bill um and I'll go over the changes um
this bill uh prohibits the transport of
miners by any school Personnel for any
medical appointments visits um without
parent or um a Guardians permission what
the add to this is is that um the school
district shall adopt a policy
prohibiting a school district Personnel
from transporting a mining or
accompanying a miner during transport
except emergency transport for a medical
appointment mental uh mental health
appointment or a visit that includes any
type of mental health evaluation
treatment or counseling or any other
health related appointment or visit
without the know know and approval of
the Minor's parent or gly unless he or
she is following a published School
District emergency health or medical
emergency protocol or policy um so it is
designed to protect both the minor and
the school Personnel um first we need to
make sure that districts have in place a
policy for emergent situation I'm a
retired intensive care nurse um so I
went to two different school districts
and ask for their policies for emergent
things because this is separating
emergent from other things so um and I
did find that neither of them had
policies um on emergent by emerging I
mean the kid that falls off the off the
swing and it's it falls and its head is
uh bleeding and they're unconscious or
um that type of emergent thing so in
speaking to the business office at um my
SAU they said well we have a policy for
transport that that uh you know you call
the nurse and if the nurse isn't
available you get in touch with the
administrator so you know I did explain
that what I meant was you know Well
everybody's trained in that and I said
well trained in that is different than
having a policy so I did get the policy
from my district and another the one
from my district is date it's under um
the care the role of the school nurse
and it's B dated 2008 so they will be
updating that but first we need to make
sure that they have some type of policy
in effect for that not just training but
a policy um so um I found and as I say I
found that their only requirements were
under health and Define the school nurse
and it was dated uh times have changed
since 2008 um this bill would expand an
injury or illness policy to make it
clear
that the responsibility for transport is
in the hands of the parent or the
guardian and not the responsibility of
school Personnel it also puts into place
the need for the school district to have
a strong policy defining the emergent uh
health or mental health incident
protocol so that the state staff are all
clear on what their expectations are in
those cases and I think that's very very
clear because um you need to know what
your expectations are and what your
limitations are so as I say this is to
protect the children as well as um to uh
protect the staff from being put into a
situation where they really don't know
um what their responsibility is or what
they should do so with that I I'm
questions thank you for presenting your
representative it was that clear good
for me
huh okay thank you very much for being
um no
cards there there's no other uh cards
does anyone else want to speak to this
bill see none we'll close the hearing
and in about 15 minutes we have our bill
of the
day
Patty
e
turn on my microphone um we're going to
quickly um exec house build 231 which we
just heard um with uh the prime sponsor
representative
a second and then you can explain
it
okay um represent Noble uh would you
have a motion on House Bill 231 move a
to
pass thank you I'll second
it
um representative um Noble do you have
any comment on your motion um yes I'd
like to introduce
Amendment
H yes um thank you and uh I'll second
OTP any further discussion um from the
represent Bon uh thank you um in our
discussion it was we we notice that it
requires school districts to adopt a
policy but it doesn't have anything
about applying to public charter schools
and I bring this up because we've been
told that if there is a policy that we
want to be applied to public charter
schools at well we have to actually um
state it clearly in the legislation
clerk was a question all right
yeah okay motions to adopt the amendment
uh Vice chairman noville yeah yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tensar
yes representative NATO yes
representative
Woodcock I'm sorry okay representative
Hall
yes representative B bon no
representative Harvey no representative
kuger yes representative Snodgrass no
and chairman cordelli yes 13 Ys and
three
Nays uh represent Noble did you want to
make a further amendment to pass with
Amendment
and that's 0603
H discussion on the
otpa
sepa uh oh you yeah I'll second that any
further
clerk motion is otpa vice chairman Noble
yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
yes representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris
sorry representa NATO yes representative
Cornell yes representative Murray no
representative
Hall yes representative
bon no representative Harvey
no representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass no no and
guess
okay no
um if there's no Minority Report is the
consent okay or would you want it on the
regular
calendar
consent thank you very much so we will
move uh to the next bill to be heard
which is House Bill
555 relative to the required Holocaust
and genocide study requirements for an
adequate public educ
and representative Reed is all ready to
go thank you representative thank you Mr
chair and thank you honorable members of
the committee for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 10
which is New Market and new fields and
before I begin my testimony I did email
the committee um I've also passed out
the uh Amendment before you and while
all of my testimony will in fact be on
the bill the the intent of the the bill
and the intent of the amendment are the
same so it's it's largely the same
testimony anyway I wanted um to
circumvent this hearing becoming a
4-Hour heated debate about which
historical incident does or does not
constitute genocide and so the the
primary change in the amendment before
you is look I'm just a representative
from New Market I have a master's degree
and and what have you and and um I've
researched um this issue sadly
extensively but there are people in the
world who have um studied and argued
over this topic more hours than we could
possibly dedicate and have more
expertise than all the people in this
room combined um and those people are
primarily uh members of of the United
Nations International court of justice
and international criminal court and
they are the ones that adjudicate what
is what Constitution gen aside and what
doesn't and so the amendment for
you takes out of my hands the idea of
what is a genocide and what isn't and
and puts it where it
belongs
so the reason I don't want that to be
this hearing arguing about the specifics
of any particular historical incident or
conflict is because that's not the point
and while we can all disagree very
vehemently on particulars of of specific
incidents I I would be hardpressed to
imagine anyone in this room really
anywhere disagreeing with the intent of
the
bill this the Genesis of this
bill is as you know the word genocide
has become more popular in the last
couple of years and upon first hearing
it it's kind of shocking and rightfully
so right it's the mother of all evils
it's the worst of the worst that
Humanity has to
offer and it raised the question well
what is a genocide
and I can tell you I'm one of the most
prolific legislators here I put in 14 16
roughly bills a gear and I research all
of those bills extensively and I have
never had such a hard time researching a
topic as I have had researching this
because as much as I thought well of
course we know what genocide is when you
actually look into it and the things
that comprise
genocide I had to take breaks every few
minutes if I was reading about
particular practice is because it is
absolutely gut-wrenching You're Not a
Human Being if you don't react strongly
to researching this topic so I did start
researching it because when I was in
school the reason it was I think so
shocking to hear the word being used
again when I was in
school I was I had Holocaust and
genocide studies and genocide was almost
synonomous with the Jewish Holocaust
perpetrated upon the Jewish people by
the Nazis in in World War II and that
was it and I think I mean it was awful
we saw the worst of the worst we saw
videos and images that made you want to
vomit but when I was learning about this
this is genocide there was definitely a
sense of wow Humanity really messed up
that time we really screwed that one up
good thing we've evolved good thing
we've learned our lesson and we're not
going to do that
anymore the danger of teaching it just
as a single historical
incident is that you feel in the clear
you feel like there's no way it's a done
deal we don't have to worry about that
it's in the history books
that the problem is it is definitely not
over this is a lesson that Humanity does
not seem to
learn because whether or not you want to
argue over one specific incident or not
there are at least a handful of
incidents happening right now that are
questions very strong questions of
whether or not they are genocide we
aren't learning this lesson this is a
thing we keep doing to each
other and if there's nothing else we
teach it should be how to be good human
beings and live on this planet
together and so I think it's extremely
exceedingly important and I know that
you had a very very unpopular Bill
trying to remove Holocaust and genocide
studies as a requirement entirely and
I'm sitting here doing the opposite if
there's I I'm sorry it's more important
than reading and writing in arithmetic
it really is because if we can't learn
how to not murder and Slaughter and
torture each other then what the heck
here by the way in researching this
there's a whole bunch of organizations I
will be deferring to the UN repeatedly
over and over again but there are a
whole bunch of organizations that study
this and it turns out and I didn't know
this but maybe you do Keen State our
very own Kee state has a holocaust and
genocide studies um and and are in and
of themselves experts um I did look to
them as a potential Source I don't think
as far as I could tell I could not find
them having listed a specific list of
genocides I will say just for the sake
of the amendment by uh kicking it over
to the list of genocides that have been
adjudicated by the international court
of justice um those are three those are
only three if you look at the list of
things that depending on the definition
have been considered genocide it's
dozens and dozens but only three and
that is the genocide perpetrated upon
the Jewish people by the Nazis which
killed approximately 7 million Jewish
people the Bosnian genocide which killed
approximately 60,000 people
and the Rwanda genocide which killed
approximately 800,000 people there are
other incidents like Cambodia in The
Killing Fields where Millions have died
but those are not included in that list
so when I defer to icj it is the most
narrow most conservative list that
exists so history it's the end of World
War
II the world is coming to the
realization that uh 7 million Jewish
people have have been killed and not
just killed but killed in the worst
possible way with attempts to eradicate
3 million non-jewish Polish people have
been targeted and killed 1 and a half
million Ro uh Ro excuse me we have used
the slur gypsies but um I I don't is it
the Romas the the people who we have
historically called gypsies were
killed and so um the League of Nations
existed after World War one here's World
War II this is just unfathomably
terrible and so the UN is formed to try
to stop anything like this from
happening both the the war itself and
the atrocities that occurred during the
war from happening again to help um
preserve International Peace there is a
Polish lawyer by the name of rapael Lyin
who would later uh be very active in the
nurg trials who is the one who coined
the term genocide genocide coming from
the Latin um same atmology where we get
the word Gene uh a tribe or family a
clan and side meaning to
kill uh he would later push for through
his studies push through for the
adoption by the UN of what would become
the genocide convention where we have
our standardized definition of
genocide um and that convention is
mostly based on liyin's uh research and
work also um this was adopted the
genocide convention was adopted in 1948
which contains the definition of
genocide which I have in the bill and
the amendment as something that needs to
be taught the definition um also adopted
in 1948 for the same reasons is the UN
Universal Declaration on human
rights so the UN definition from liyin
it's any of the following acts that have
with the intent to destroy in or in part
and Destroy later through studies has
been qualified as as such meaning even
if it's not intended to destroy them
physically if it's destroying who they
are as an identity um then that counts
uh so with the inent to destroy and
whole or in part a national ethnic
racial or religious group either
killing the serious bodily or mental
harm to the group deliberately
inflicting upon the group conditions of
life that are calculated to bring about
their destruction in whole or in part
these are things like man-made forced
famine or this intentional spread of
disease uh the the force prevention of
births of the group and forcibly
transferring the group any one of these
elements constitutes his genocide if it
has the intent to destroy that group
many of those that long list of of
potential genocides um have almost all
of those
elements so interestingly this
definition the words not the citation
back to the UN genocide convention but
the words already exist in our RSA but
they do not exist as an instruction to
teach they exist because we say
Holocaust and genocide studies and then
in RSA we Define genocide and we
conveniently use by and large the UN
definition of genocide but then we don't
tell teachers to teach that definition I
think the definition is very important
in addition all of those groups that
have studied this like Keen state um
have studied this extensively and
they've come up with several things
these are not part of the genocide
convention but these are widely agreed
upon uh characteristics of genocide uh
one is the 10 stages and another one is
six common tools of genocide um in the
amendment I specifically point out that
the common stages and the tools of
genocide should be
taught the 10 stages really fast
basically it's an overarching picture of
otherizing a group and and creating that
separation more and more extreme so that
you can eventually have an excuse to
violate their rights and eventually
destroy them that's classification
symbolization discrimination
dehumanization organization polarization
preparation persecution extermination
and finally denial denial that the
genocide ever happened the six tools and
I think this is potentially even more
important to
teach violent massacres or mass killing
by things like those Force conditions
famine um disease systematic rape
including the potentially rape camps
which have happened uh and other sexual
violence the this is used as
psychological Terror as well as a way to
change the uh the group and prevent the
births of that group but basically put
the preferred group have those births
happen
instead um other Force birth prevention
such as Force sterilization forced
abortion and the transferring of
children
forc deportations or ethnic cleansing of
a region including things like death
marches the use of
trains concentration camps detention
sensors en forced labor and finally
cultural eraser and the reason I think
these tools are extremely important is
because we need students who understand
that when they see any of these things
when they see those things a red flag
should go up for them anywhere in the
world
so I told you about my
experience that genocide was just this
one thing this one thing that happened
historically and it's over and thank God
is isn't it good it's over as I'm
studying this I had never in my life
considered for
example that the treatment of the
indigenous people of North America was a
genocide having studied this it's
unquestionable to me personally that
that's exactly what it was that my
country which I love has engaged in
atrocities and one of those atrocities
is the genocide of indigenous people who
were
here I can say that about my own country
and that is why it's important to teach
because I would have never
thought I would have never thought the
danger of having this limited
instruction as we currently have in RSA
where it's just Holocaust and genocide
studies that's a bad stuff y'all like
that's basically all our current RSA
says it doesn't even have a minimum of
instruction and no real like historic
widespread historic instruction on what
is actually happening when we talk about
genocide so no minimum no instruction
and the danger of that is
that you're we have generations of
people who don't think it can happen
here who don't see those flags and go oh
maybe we're the bad guy or maybe our
friends are the bad guy they don't it
doesn't it doesn't generate for them an
alarm system and it really
should so I do understand that um you've
had lots of opposition emails and
opposition in the room my understanding
is most of that opposition is in
reference to one conflict and whether or
not that conflict should be included in
the definition of genocide I do hope
that my um a proposed amendment here
which rightly puts the list of genocides
to be taught in the hands of the highest
Authority in the world on the topic um
can bring everybody together around this
purpose because the intent is extremely
important we are not doing enough to
make citizens who are going to be aware
when they see the world and see terrible
things happening in the
world um so I hope this brings us all
together in the room and elsewhere and I
hope we can all agree that um we don't
ever want to see genocide ever again
with that I will take questions
thank
you do have questions for the
representative uh I just I had one you
mentioned um something about a
flag a flag a red flags as mental red
flags as in something should ping in our
heads when we see these types of um
tactics being used you see people like
if you were to see four sterilizations
that should ping in your head oh this is
one of those tools of genocide you see
people loaded up on trains or forced
into death marches forced famine that
should pay in your head tool of genocide
so I didn't mean a literal flag thank
you represent Freeman thank you Mr chair
um representative Reed do you have a
recommendation for an age group that
school not in the bill it's in the RSA
further questions the RSA that currently
has Holocaust and genocide studies but
it's a very vague and very brief mention
school R Cornell Thank you Mr chair
thank you for this testimony I just
wondering if you talked at all or worked
at all with the commission that is I am
aware that there is a commission I did
not this I I'm not going to lie this is
um I've been very deeply personally
impacted um by this topic not I don't
mean to say that I've been personally
impacted by genocide I have not but
studying this and and and the
conversations around this topic have
been ex exceedingly emotional for me so
um it's just something I felt like I had
a a moral obligation to
do thank you for the questions see none
thank you very
I thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I appear in opposition uh to
this bill I I I don't think first of all
I don't think you're that it's necessary
but more
importantly I I hope that the committee
will take a moment to sort of reflect on
do we want to be instructing our schools
that what they ought to be relying on is
the United
Nations uh view of the world uh for the
studying of uh of what constitutes
genocide uh and and related things the
United
Nations the United Nations organizations
I whether it's is it the international
criminal court I think it was the
international criminal court that has um
issued an arrest warrant for prime
minister Netanyahu that that's the
that's the uh um that's how responsible
the international criminal court um uh
uh is um that that will will issue an
arrest warrant for the prime minister of
a country uh that was you know viciously
attacked in in October of 2023 and
responded um I I I can't help thinking
that particularly when you consider the
original bill and although the the um
the amendment purports to take out you
know the specific reference for example
to the Palestinian genocide I have to
say that I must have missed that um uh
where the Palestinian genocide was um uh
but it it strikes me that what this is
an attempt to do is to kind of draw an
equivalency um you know it's well as
this this was a but so is this um that
kind of thing and um and frankly um
there is no equivalency here there's
there's there's
one what happened on October in October
of 2023 there's one right side and one
wrong side there's no equivalency um in
terms of what happened or in terms of
Israel's response to it um and I think
that uh to the extent that the
suggestion is that we should rely on the
United Nations and its view of the world
uh in light of all that we have seen
happen with the United Nations in so
many contexts over you know the last 10
years or whatever think it seems to me
is a very very bad idea so for all of
those reasons I would urge you I think
the I think the current Statute in terms
of what it what it requires to be
studied is is uh is entirely adequate
the fact that the that the uh that uh
the sponsor indicated that well the def
there is a definition of what
constitutes a genocide in the statute
already but it doesn't require that that
uh uh students be taught that it doesn't
prohibit that either I mean is there if
if uh if if teachers think that that's
something that's important that's you
know that students should be taught
there's nothing that's prevents them
from doing that um so I just don't see
why you know to the extent that that's
the argument why this is why this is
necessary at any rate I again it seems
to me I don't think that this
legislature or this state wants to be
relying on um the United Nations view uh
and these and the various organization
remember what isn't isn't what's the
unus isn't that the um the the uh the
group that uh is United Nations funded
that was uh uh providing quote unquote
relief to the uh to the Palestinians and
many many of their members were part of
the uh of the of the Invaders on October
7th so the idea that um we should be uh
placing faith and trust in the United
Nations is something I think is not a
very good idea um with that I I I hope
you'll decide to itl this Bill thank you
very much representative yes
representative hard yes so you you
mentioned um
equivalency
and I'm wondering uh what your thought
is in terms of um the Holocaust
which the numbers that she read off were
definitely horrifying um if this bill
would
then cause an equivalency that would
diminish the Holocaust and water it down
um so that everything can be equal well
well no I mean that's I think that's a
very valid point because it seems to me
you know I'm I'm certainly not
suggesting that the only you know
atrocity that in history has been um has
been the Holocaust I'm not suggesting
that but I do think that it's that it's
a fair thing to say that that was you
know by far the the worst
situation um of of some kind of a
genocide that we've seen I mean it was
it is Way Beyond anything else it seems
to me that that we've seen and you know
I I mean I know the original bill I
talked about you know the the uh
treatment of of Native Americans I don't
for a moment suggest that we you know
that there was any that that Native
Americans uh you know uh in history were
true that there was anything um uh but
deplorable treatment of of Native
Americans um but I don't think that that
that it it rises to the level of what
happened during the Holocaust as bad as
it may have been and I think that um you
know that to particular I mean the thing
I found particularly offensive about the
about the original bill was the the the
the the suggestion that somehow there's
a there was a Palestinian genocide that
was you know that was somehow we should
be taking that into account and
considering that uh Visa the Holocaust
it's just it's completely apples and
oranges as far as I'm
concerned thank you yes represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for coming in front of us
and taking my questions I just have a
question for you do you think Reading
Writing and arithmetic are very
do thank you very much thank you very
Dia
you turn on your microphone just press
the button the silver
button y there you go
oh thank you um thank you to Chairman
gardelli and members of the House educ
ation committee uh for giving me this
opportunity to speak in opposition to HB
555 FN I'm not much of a public speaker
so I hope you'll bear with me I
submitted a letter in January that
outlined some of my thoughts about why
Israel's military action in Gaza after
an unprovoked invasion into its borders
the massacre of
1,200 innocent lives and the Abduction
of over 200 others does not constitute a
genocide genocide is a very specific
crime requiring intent and Israel's
attempts to rescue the hostages and
locate the leaders of the attack do not
despite the unfortunate deaths of
civilians constitute an attempt to
exterminate the Palestinian people but I
don't want to repeat everything I said
in the letter here instead I want to
concentrate today on two other reasons
to reject this proposed bill first it's
unassailable that there's a rise in
anti-Semitism in this country around the
world and New Hampshire unfortunately is
no exception as someone who has worked
in public schools around the state both
as the former chair of the Jewish
federations anti-Semitism committee and
as the administrator of Civic 603 in New
Hampshire Civics program I am personally
aware of some of the incidents occurring
in our state in schools elementary
middle and high schools I've spoken to
teachers parents and students there are
the usual swas on desks at bathrooms and
school bus windows and there have been
Nazi salutes and comments like kill the
Jew you stupid Jew what do you expect
from a dumb Jew and I've headed up to
hear Jew whatever your particular views
are on Israel's response to October 7th
it cannot be seriously gain said that
adding a mandatory discussion about the
ongoing situation in the Middle East
will F more Discord in
anti-Semitism second although I am
speaking completely in my personal
capacity and not as a representative of
the state's Holocaust and genocide
education commission I am aware from our
meetings that schools are having a
difficult time implementing the existing
statute the rules implemented to
effectuate the statute and by the way uh
in response to representative Reed's
comments There are rules that were
promulgated by the Board of
Education outlining what should be
taught um pursuant to this statute the
rules did not go into effect until 2022
and 2023 Academic Year and teachers are
themselves still learning about the
topic adding the Middle East situation
one that has sparked so much controversy
around the country where events change
from day to day where we have not yet
benefited from the lens of history and
where a person could spend literally the
entire four years of high school trying
to understand the geopolitics of Middle
East of the Middle East is imprudent and
impractical as a Jewish person whose
relatives suffered during pilgrims and
during the Holocaust and Who as a
consequence understands the importance
of Israel and believes as Martin Luther
King Jr said that peace in Israel
requires the security and territorial
Integrity of Israel I am deeply saddened
and offended by the original proposal
and as someone who has been involved in
education in New Hampshire Public
Schools since my retirement from the
practice of law I am simply astonished
that anyone would think that the
proposed requirement would not wreak
havoc in school if it were Incorporated
on a mandatory basis into the
curriculum finally although I'm not
prepared to speak um with respect to the
proposed amendment that's before you
today I will not that has a number of
significant problems the United States
is not a member of the icj or the ICC
and has not adopted the universal
Declaration of Human
Rights I wonder whether the amendment is
an attempt to uh to backdoor the
existing proposal um
through through by using much broader
language thank you and um if you have
any questions I'll try to answer
them thank you very much good job thank
you uh any questions oh sorry I I don't
see any so thank you very much for being
GT good afternoon chairman and members
of the committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak today my name is
Allison gerton I serve as the executive
director for the Jewish Federation of
New Hampshire um you have already
received the letter that we sent
outlining our concerns with the proposed
amendment so I will f Fus my time today
on what we feel is most critical in the
past 15 months the Jewish Federation of
New Hampshire has received reports of
anti-Semitic incidents in three
different schools across our state this
is not abstract this is happening here
in our communities and we must be
mindful of the impact our laws and our
policies have on fostering either
understanding or division the amendment
before you inserting the term
Palestinian genocide into the Holocaust
and genocide education statute does not
Advance historical education it advances
a divisive political agenda the
Holocaust and genocide education law was
created to teach students about well
documented universally recognized
genocides ensuring that we learn from
the past to prevent future
atrocities adding a term that is highly
politicized and deeply disputed not only
weakens the Integrity of this law but it
risks turning classrooms into
Battlegrounds for political narratives
rather than spaces for factual learning
this proposal has real consequences
regardless of intent framing Israel's
actions as genocide promotes a
misleading and inflammatory narrative
that contributes to anti-Semitism it
introduces bias into educational
standards it risks fostering hostility
towards Jewish students and the broader
Jewish Community the international
Holocaust remembrance alliance
definition of anti-semitism which New
Hampshire adopted into law last year
provides clear guidance on how
anti-semitic rhetoric can manifest
including in ways that distort or
demonize Jewish identity and the Jewish
State we must be cautious not to
introduce language into our education
system that could fuel div division or
hatred for these reasons I urge this
committee to reject the amendment the
original Law serves a vital purpose
ensuring students understand the
catastrophic consequences of true
genocide this amendment to distorts that
mission let's keep Holocaust and
genocide education focused on history
and not on politics thank you thank you
very much any
questions see none thank you for being
good afternoon everybody Mr chairman
committee members thank you for having
me here
today um as uh I'm Terry Ock
representative ter o rock from Keane a
few years ago I began working on a
project highlighting what I have since
termed crimes against humanity in the
United
States what brought that Curiosity about
was the daily death totals occurring due
to
covid-19 my initial thought was could
this be a genocide in the making and has
there ever been a genocide in this
country that would be yes what my
research did turn up was the woolful
lack of American History taught in our
schools time and time again I would find
some historical event and think to
myself I never knew that why weren't we
taught that in
School the events that I am referring to
would be inhumane treatment and crimes
against Native Americans and at the
beginning of this country's history
Africans now known as black and brown
Americans we were never taught about the
Trail of Tears the forced removal of
Native Americans from their lands to
Oklahoma thousands died while on route
or the many wars that occurred such as
the Sand Creek Massacre the Pico War the
creek Wars to name a
few human bondage or slavery was allowed
until it wasn't but in the meantime
there were many rebellions and massacres
that took place and were never Tau about
one example is the Tulsa Race massacre
in Tulsa Oklahoma in
1921 I had never heard of that event
until I happened upon a nation a copy of
National Geographic
who had a piece on the 100th anniversary
in
2021 events like these and so many more
like the unlawful incarceration of
Japanese American citizens during World
War II are a part of American history
and need to be acknowledged learned
about and hopefully learn lessons
from I ask that you seriously and
thoughtfully consider adding more
accurate past americ ameran history to
school curriculum so students can have
full knowledge of our nation's
Beginnings that would include The Good
the Bad and the Ugly and I thank you for
your
time thank
you yes
representative uh thank thank you very
much Mr chair and thank you for taking
my question so um I've heard from a
number of speakers today that you know
um a number of events um were not taught
in their school and they they' never
heard of that I grew up in in a public
school setting and so forth and a lot of
those events in fact most of the ones
that I've mentioned I I did hear about
and I'm just wondering if um if you
could speak a little bit on
um
maybe maybe these things are um taught
and we don't remember them or maybe um
it's inequality in our schools or
um something that that or maybe we don't
actually know what's being taught in our
schools just
because I'm confused in that I I did
know about the Trail of Tears and the
Japanese detention centers could you
speak on that please thank you okay to
the best of my ability I will I really
never heard of the the Trail of Tears um
the the only thing I remember ever
learning learning about in in school
whether it was high school or I don't
know midd Junior High whatever was
um yeah the the Indians they were here
first we they were referred to as
Indians at the time they were here first
and then you
know the the white white people came and
we just took I mean it was kind of
glossed over I guess is what I'm saying
so so no I had never ever heard of the
Trail of Tears um
slavery uh yes how um um the black and
brown people were brought to America
again we learned about it but it was
kind of glossed
over and I think what I I what I was
trying to um bring about in in in what I
was talking about was that maybe more of
the meat of our history needs to be
taught um to students of an appropriate
age which would be high school um and so
that they know exactly the background of
our history um which is why I ended off
with The Good the Bad and the Ugly and
hopefully um lessons can be learned from
that thank
you represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question representative so
you all these things you didn't hear
about when you were in high school or
Junior High I do remember actually there
was a book that I read when I was in
school about the trailer tier so I I
guess I was fortunate enough to have a
teacher who did that I actually have a
two-part question okay um how do you
feel about local control or curriculum
and I think that's important because we
do have a long run the books and I
there's a lot of times that I think we
should defer to the teacher on what they
should teach um just because they know
Their audience how do you feel about the
local controler
curriculum oh wow um I'm sorry I wasn't
expecting that question I'm really not
prepared for that and that that's my
honest that's my honest answer yes you
know if I had a week to think about it I
could come back and say got you know
where to find you find me in reps Hall I
app I appreciate your hesty thank you
yeah okay thank did you have a two-part
I did but that's okay that's okay okay
okay further questions see none thank
you very much
thank you for caring so much about
education and talking about all of this
my name is D Cohen I am a resident of
New Hampshire and I'm opposed to HB 555
I'm a mother of four
children and I'm extremely worried when
facts are taken over by deliberate false
narratives HP
555 would mandate the inclusion of the
fabricated pal in genocide alongside
Holocaust Education I come from a family
of Holocaust Survivors and to me this is
not equivalent in any possible way and
taking the UN report as an
example it is not the fact there are
other sides to this and I don't think
that it should be decided here what is
factual and what is not it is what we
want to give our kids the values
um
and there has not been any Palestinian
genocide and in fact the population of
the Palestinians grew tenfolds since
1948 they're 14 million now so it's the
opposite of what is defined as genocide
this false narrative however if taught
to kids basically follows the Hamas
propaganda and will lead to teaching
kids fake history and what's called
Holocaust inversion it is wrong it will
radicalize children in New Hampshire it
will cause demonizing of
Israel and anti-Semitism it is offensive
and
anti-semitic and I don't think it's what
we want to teach our kids we want to
teach our kids values and facts that are
not argued anymore thank you for your
time thank you very much for being here
any
questions see none thank you again thank
borrow good afternoon Mr chairman
honorable members of the committee thank
you so much for having me here and for
allowing me to speak my name is Karen
bar or and I'm here in opposition of HB
555 I'm here in a few different
capacities today the first uh as a VP of
Civic engagement in fighting
anti-Semitism for the Israeli American
Council a National
Organization the second as uh the wife
of a business owner here in New
Hampshire who cares very deeply about
this community and finally as a mother
of uh two young children and for those
who have seen me handing out the letter
uh soon to be a third um who is deeply
deeply concerned and and
petrified about the indoctrination that
we're seeing in schools over the past
couple years
we've been witnessing the moral decay of
our education system in what seems like
a posttruth era activists are using
classrooms to push false narratives that
are indoctrinating our children and
contributing to hate and divisiveness in
our
communities the importance of Holocaust
and genocide studies is
indisputable one must understand the
past in order to ensure that these
horrific events do not repeat themselves
not today and not in the
future but allowing toxicity and
indoctrination such as relying on the UN
narrative that we know pushes the
fabricated Narrative of the Palestinian
genocide does nothing but promote
hate war is a horrific thing but we need
to be clear we need to teach the truth
there has never been a Palestinian
genocide if anything the population of
the Palestinians has just grown um since
1948 and that's not what genocide looks
like rep Reed spoke eloquently and
almost convincingly about in arguing for
her new version of the bill which uh
does not specify the Palestinian
genocide as it did in the original but
does bring the narratives of the UN the
ICC the icj which those who have been
here sat here before me Express
addressed exactly the issues with them
including unra who we all know had
participants in the atrocities of
October 7th and many other things that
the UN has been pushing for that have
been anti-semitic to say the
least teaching the narrative plays into
the same propaganda that Hamas a
terrorist organization is using to
justify the atrocities of October 7th
the largest Massacre of Jews since the
Holocaust and they're using it to turn
this into an uprise against Jewish
people worldwide we are seeing the state
of anti-Semitism in the United States
and it is appalling and
terrifying more so this is a classic
example of Holocaust
inversion which uses this biggest
tragedy to happen to the Jews against us
and is one of the C lists for modern
anti-Semitism that we're seeing
today to summarize HB 555 promotes the
trend of using our classrooms to teach
false narratives leading to increased
intolerance and radical radicalization
of children across the state I beg you
stand for the truth stand against
indoctrination stand against hate vote
against this bill the thank you so much
for your time if anyone has questions
I'm happy to answer them thank you very
very much for being here yes
representative your turn thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so um we've heard a a lot uh
today about um how this bill would be um
teaching false truths in our schools um
is it your belief that what is being
taught in our schools now is truthful in
which case I'm wondering why the purpose
of the
bill there are many different things
that are being taught in schools um I
think that there is definitely an issue
in education today and indoctrination
and the reason that I'm here is to
oppose this specific bill that I think
only would add to that um indoctrination
and changing of the facts but by all
means there are many issues with
education and I wish that I could be on
every single issue um unfortunately in
the past couple of years I've been
dedicated to fighting anti-Semitism
within school systems and one of the
things that we're seeing is an increase
of anti-Semitism that is tied directly
to things that are being taught in
schools and we're then seeing it on
campus it doesn't start on campus it
starts in their
schools any further questions see none
thank you very much and best of luck
with your pregnancy thank
um cental Emory emmer I'm sorry for the
okay you can hear me all
right uh I am an Turkish immigrant of 23
years uh this bill this proposed Bill
I've seen different versions of it in in
different states Rhode Island
Massachusetts a variety of places the
reason I am involv and deeply care about
um education Bill proposals such as this
one is I work very closely with the
Immigrant communities in our area
primarily Turkish but a lot of
immigrants and not necessarily just from
uh Middle Eastern
countries what I have seen in the past
as then there's conversations education
Bill conversations that involve claims
of genocide Holocaust and
Etc these bills ended up creating a
negative environment at our in our
schools our children um who come from uh
countries or societies um where such
such claims have been made from have
seen a lot of Oppression there have been
hate crimes crimes documented hate
crimes even that took
place just in the last 5 years or so
there has been a half a dozen or perhaps
more documented cases of um uh verbal
abuses and various attacks in in our
school systems just because there are
children uh who come from those
backgrounds in my case it has been
Turkish versus Armenian in another case
it could be Jewish versus Arab doesn't
matter I understand all the
sensitivities of the situation I really
Commander representative read about the
fact that there is an amended language
in the bill that takes away specific
verb verbage for uh specific societies
countries heritages I really appreciate
that however I find find that um many
members have spoken today are against uh
this bill completely because there's a
reference to United Nations just want to
clarify one
thing uh United Nations across so many
other bodies internationally is one that
has still the most globally accepted
body probably I'm not an expert of the
topic but the reason United Nations is
in here is they are the global body that
have studied this topic in the most
compreh prehensive way without that we
will be left to our own devices and
there will be a lot of fighting and
arguments and never a peaceful
resolution maybe there's a better option
maybe there's a better outcome that is
more inclusive and less discriminating
to different members of our
society I just wanted to let you know
all of those thank you for um dealing
with this very sensitive very delicate
topic I would like to see less
discrimination and More inclusivity in
our societies doesn't matter what
background we really come from I do deal
with this a lot in the Civil Society and
uh I see what happens to immigrants on
top of that vend there finger pointed
and um different types of hate or
historical um historically sensitive
topics are shared with our children we
do have documented cases that end up
creating sad sad outcomes thank you so
much don't want to take more your time
but happy to answer if you have any
questions as well thank you any
questions see none thank you very much
I'll just mention that Friday I did have
a a call from the Turkish Council
General uh in opposition to this
hello is it working yes thank
you my name is larara bashof I am
American I am
Jewish I am here to stop this amendment
to this amendment to the law HB 555 from
happening thank you chairman cordelli
and to this committee for the
opportunity to speak with you
today if I
may with all due respect why has any New
Hampshire House of Representative
decided there is a Palestinian
genocide while I know with 100%
certainty it is not true Israel is
simply defending itself our
representative should not be stating it
as a fact this is not only hugely
inacurate
inaccurate but it is massively
Dangerous by including this term are
just Sentiments of it in any way in any
leg legislation does just
this the danger to Jewish Americans is
making this declaration in making this
declaration declaration cannot be
underscored enough anti-Semitism was bad
enough before October 7th
2023 no one can refute the fact that it
is Raging with physical security at risk
as a result
now if this bill were to to pass New
Hampshire is clearly stating Israel does
not have a right to
exist that is not what the majority of
Americans believe or how they vote I do
not think anyone here wants to be
responsible for even suggesting
this even considering the term
Palestinian genocide and whatever
fashion will incite either even further
anti-Semitism as I stated I am American
and I am Jewish I have very sadly lived
with anti-Semitism my whole life without
out I feel even less safe in my own
country now than I have ever felt Israel
made the grave mistake of letting its
guard down on October 7th 2023 by not
protecting its citizens from Pure
Evil My Country the United States of
America must not follow suit my country
has the absolute responsibility to
protect me by passing this law I would
most definitively be dramatically left
safe what we all know anti-Semitism is a
disease that spreads like wildfire we
see how it's ripped at the core of our
universities with this law what this law
would do is start this process much
earlier in our young people's
lives let us be clear we own we all know
that even babies are being indoctrinated
to hate Jewish people from babies being
at the in quotes ceremony where the
murdered BS mother and children were
finally released to their Insidious
school studies damning Jews New
Hampshire is at Great risk of
systematically doing exactly the same by
bringing this term or any sentiment of
it to our children in our
schools in good conscience we cannot
update any any law that suggests such a
thing the lies of your fellow Americans
are at Major risk here and the minds of
Young Americans must not be inaccurately
and Mal maliciously indoctrinated as we
are witnessing in other places we are
really better than this thank you for
listening I appreciate it I know that
heard some emotional um some emotion
earlier today I'm I'm Jewish I
experienced it I'm 56 years old there's
not a day in my life where I haven't
experienced this and it's getting worse
because of this exact thing thank you
very much for your testimony any
questions see none thank you very much
for being here thank you very much I
appreciate it and Rabbi Jonathan spear
Sheriff
this still still on still working yes
thank you hi uh good afternoon um and
thank you Mr chairman and uh honorable
Representatives um I'm Rabbi Jonathan
spirette uh from Nashua I serve Temple
Beth Abraham which is a Jewish
congregation centered in NASA and
serving their region uh and I'm honored
like Dina to be a member of the New
Hampshire Commission on Holocaust and
genocide studies uh I'm a former High
School teacher briefly um of American
history hisory and literature among
other things engaged in other Civic and
philanthropy education primarily in the
Jewish Community I'm um I'm revising
what I came in with in light of uh
representative Reed's revision too so I
want to I want to make sure to say this
to the point um uh and I should say also
I'm the parent of two alums of the Nash
public schools and and one hopefully
about to be alum for the last time um in
one in in one hat and I don't represent
the commission but a couple of us are
here um I do want to recommend to
everyone the uh both the the minutes of
the commission which met just a few
weeks ago and the regulations uh I think
Dana referred to that that actually
implementing regulations which was a
painstaking process that that I don't
understand by which the State Board of
Education is that right um takes the
intents and um and actually many of the
things including many of the specifics
that were in the original proposal were
you know were considered and and kind of
worked in and um and uh the committee
certainly should should look at those
and and I do want so B to be reassuring
to everybody that we we take this very
seriously as a uh as a democracy
education for the present it's Holocaust
and genocide studies and and I will and
because it's really a dimension of
democracy studies and civic education
and as a member of the Jewish Community
with my own set of experiences and
experiences of my group but also as a as
a as a patriot I think and a Civic
leader in my community I see this as not
just about the past but very much about
the the present and uh and uh and the
future and see the strength of New
Hampshire trying to be brought to bear
and making sure these things don't
happen and seeing them where they do um
and I've been before this committee
before in different iterations talking
about how to do other things to invest
better in our social studies education
um to deal with the divisive Concepts
framework which is preventing uh many
teachers from even delving into this
area at all and feeling uh confused and
one of the the things you can do is to
kind of resolve uh resolve those things
um I certainly would be grateful if the
attention to this bill and the
commission and the Mandate would
increase knowledge about it and urgency
about teaching um Holocaust and genocide
studies generally and uh and kind of
democracy and Civics um even more even
more
generally um I do want to say that um I
came in originally to to oppose the bill
as formulated because of the the
Palestine proposition as someone who is
um an American Jew and a Zionist who has
been a supporter and still is of
Palestinian national rights uh for 37
years since I was a student in Jerusalem
um taught to me by my by my rabbis in
Jerusalem actually as a matter of Jewish
principle of Torah as we say and of and
of Zionism and um and that designating
one particular uh the experience of
Palestinians as a genocide or the
genocide taking place in the Middle East
um is not in support of peace and I
could talk about the ways and I I don't
you know it's it's a field of the bill
but I think you should know that there
are people in New Hampshire and people
that that we are connected to the Jewish
Community the Israeli American Community
who are involved in Jewish Arab
coexistence um in every kind of sphere
that you can imagine and uh wh some of
whom grew up here and uh or some of whom
are are very uh closely connected to
families here and they are uh
connections that we should be proud of
about and they continue their work even
after the atrocities of of October 7th
2023 and um they and and the people who
know them here and I you know are
resources to try to not only head off
something which is a kind of Insidious
version of interpretation of the
conflict but with something more
hopeful um I think that the other thing
that I want to say is that uh well I
think I'll say two other things one is
so I'm the parent of a of a college
student on on I'll say one of the the
more terrible campuses where um where
the where the the matter of Israel
Palestine has been happening and um and
unfortunately some of what's been
happening in education particularly as
it's trickled down into um into high
school education is that some of the
materials that are being generated about
this are are are built on such
falsehoods about what is going on and
and as much as anything else my fear is
not that we talk about it or that the
student couldn't raise the question of
Palestine but that the materials that
are most accessible to our teachers are
are terrible materials and I think
that's been been referenced before and
you know can can be happy to to add to
that um and at the same time and with
you know sort of quivering in myself and
my own emotion um I also want to be
clear something that I think I said in
my if not in my initial testimony when
we were talking about establishing this
mandate that certainly in other forums
and uh uh and uh and at the commission
is that uh if a student wants to take
what they've learned in the holoc
Holocaust and genocide education that
they've experienced and ask and say I've
heard something about Palestine or
Israel Palestine how do I learn more
about about that then then it's
education and it should be real
education based on real sources and
comprehensive and all of that so that
they can take the concepts that they are
learning and uh and apply them um and I
want to be there as a Jewish Resource as
someone who's knowledgeable and academic
um for them as I'm sure there are other
resources here I offer that to you to to
Educators to members of the public um I
do this kind of teaching in the
community um I'm not afraid of that
conversation and um but there are better
and worse ways and and some of the worst
ways we've been experiencing um in
education and I don't want them to come
to to New Hampshire um so um I think
that that is uh is what I'll say about
that and um if you have questions
otherwise thank you thank you very much
Rabbi any
questions see n thank you very much for
your
testimony is there anyone else who
wanted to speak on this
legislation
seen I will
close the hearing and uh thank everybody
very much um for uh being here and for
uh giving us your
testimony and with the committee we'll
be uh back on
um I believe 2:30 the right uh yes we
did
um and okay and for anyone who uh was
going to do reports if we could have
them U Wednesday Wednesday morning for
the reports um so I can get them in I
got
twice right that's right she's told me
three
times